so when I hear you know people get all
oh somebody so and so said that you're
an a cult okay I I mean it literally
doesn't move the needle at all for me it
is interesting to hear and I've listened
to a little bit of the rational and Ty
you've interacted with this a little bit
but it's all kind of funny in that oh
you believe that Jesus is the head of
the angels and that Michael is one of
the is like the name for Jesus as the
the the uh leader of the Angelic host
yeah yeah I I believe that's true I
believe that possesses fantastic
explanatory power both the Old and New
Testaments it's not the most important
thing to me it's not even in the top 10
or 20 the identification of Michael but
you think that makes what I believe
cultic
okay well greetings and thank you for
being here so that was a clip from a Q&A
last year that SDA pastors Ty Gibson and
David asri from lightbearers did I
responded to a portion of that at that
time but I wanted to play that clip
because we heard something that's very
common regarding the Seventh Adventist
teaching on Jesus being Michael the
Archangel which is that the SDA teaching
is simply that Jesus is the leader of
the angels and Michael is simply another
name for him and there was sort of an
attitude of if you think the SDA
teaching on this area makes them a cult
you're clearly the one in the wrong
you're the weird one that sort of thing
well I hope David watches tonight
because more than likely he is unaware
of what we are about to look at which as
I will show without question when looked
at comprehensively what the SDA Church
claims in this area is absolutely cultic
not just cultic but dambly heretical and
the Adventist Church has not been
entirely forthright in this area as I
will demonstrate now tonight's
presentation has been in the works for
quite some time time and that's because
it has required a copious amount of
reading and preparation if you are a
channel member you knew that this was
coming a while back as you all got a
behind the scenes Peak at some of the
research along the way now we are going
to be looking at a mountain a mountain
of primary source documentation that
quite frankly is going to probably blow
your mind whether you're a Christian
that's just trying to educate yourself a
former Adventist or even currently
identify as an Adventist I want to
encourage you to watch this whole
presentation even if it is an all-in-one
sitting it's going to be long but the
juice will absolutely be worth the
squeeze I can guarantee you that no
clickbait no clickbait you need to
fasten your seat belt because you are
going to be blown away because what
we're going to look at is a rabbit hole
that I went down last year and I was
absolutely shell shocked at what I found
and the role that this Doctrine plays in
the bigger theological picture and
namely the great controversy world view
I also need to note that I am greatly
greatly greatly indebted to two
individuals in particular who were of
serious help in the research and
presentation for this presentation um or
the research and preparation for this
presentation excuse me one of uh is one
of our YouTube members who will go
unnamed and the other is Jim from
Academy apologia so I do want to
publicly thank them for their help as we
storm the Gates of Hell tonight and beat
those suckers down which reminds me I'm
going to be speaking very direct tonight
it's going to be one of those nights and
I will probably be somewhat animated at
times I'm going to try and keep it
rained in but y'all know how it goes so
if that offends you consider this your
heads up okay because what we're about
to look at should righteously anger
every person who loves the true Christ
okay this is a Blasphemous Doctrine from
the pit of Hell that this organization
needs to go on public record to denounce
and apologize for the untold amount of
people that they have led astray by
teaching
this that
is unless they still stand by all of it
which as we're going to to see they have
to because the bigger role this plays in
the great controversy
Paradigm which is the heartbeat of
adventism I want to remind everyone of
what God tells us through Paul the
Apostle in 2 Corinthians 11 specifically
verses
1-4 where we
read I hope you will put up with me in a
little
foolishness yes please put up with me I
am jealous for you with a Godly
jealousy I promised you to one husband
to Christ so that I might present you as
a pure virgin to
him but I'm afraid that just as Eve was
deceived by the serpent cunning your
minds may
be somehow be led astray from your
sincere and pure devotion to
Christ for if someone comes to you and
preaches a Jesus other than the Jesus we
preached or if you receive a different
Spirit from the spirit you received or a
different gospel from the one you
accepted you put up with it readily
enough thus the reading of God's holy
word so what this
evidences is that there are false
jesuses out
there simply using the name Jesus is not
enough Paul's concern for the the
churches at Corinth was that if someone
came leading them after a different
Jesus a different
Spirit different
gospel that they would put up with such
and be led astray like Eve was with the
serpent and in his Godly jealousy for
them remaining pure to the Jesus that
Paul introduced them
to he was afraid that that would be
their end that they'd be led after an
idol
so this is a serious matter
okay and it will be shown beyond a
shadow of a doubt that the Jesus of
seventh day adventism is a false Christ
who is not
real he cannot save you he is an
idol but before getting into
it if you like what we are doing here
please consider becoming a channel
member you'll gain access to not only
our members only live streams as well as
our video library but you will also gain
access to our new behindth curtain
Discord server where you can connect
with answering adventism community
members including myself you can ask
questions get behind the scenes looks at
what's coming up and much much more if
you want to join simply visit the link
in the description box down below or
click the little join button down below
this video as a disclaimer you may have
to do so on a desktop computer for it to
work if you don't see the button if
you're on mobile but thank you thank you
thank you all so much for for your
support all right so to start we have to
look at a couple of foundational
standard claims that one can expect to
hear from the SDA Church regarding their
teaching on Michael the Archangel a
couple of which we heard put forth by
David in that intro clip although brief
but I also need to dispel an errant
objection that some incorrectly believe
about the SDA position on this this is
vital absolutely vital so please pay
very close attention
it is often assumed that because the
Seventh Adventist Church teaches that
Jesus is Michael the Archangel that
means they believe the same thing as the
Jehovah's
Witnesses that Jesus is a created
Angelic being but this isn't correct
kind of so in the
book questions on Doctrine I have an OG
copy of it
here question number eight deals with
this subject and we're going to use that
as the source to show you what these
standard claims on this subject are but
a little backstory on that source for
those who are
unaware questions on Doctrine was a book
published by the SDA Church in
1957 they put it together after
conversations that leaders had with
Evangelical apologists Walter Martin and
Donald
barnhouse this was in preparation for
the writing of Walter Martin's Infamous
book The Kingdom of the Colts which was
published eight years later later in
1965 so knowing that Martin was looking
into 7th Day adventism the SDA Church
wanted to try and clear up
misconceptions about their beliefs
especially on topics like the nature of
Christ the atonement and salvation their
goal was to show that adventism is
Christian and not a
cult this is the working definition of
cult that Martin was operating off of so
in Kingdom of the Cults he writes
quote in his study of modern American
Cults and minority religious movements
as found in his text these also believe
Dr Charles Braden Emirates professor of
Northwestern University and co-author
John C schaer and visiting professor at
scrips College made a number of
observations with which the uh this
writer agrees so talking about himself
in regard to this term cult for instance
Dr Braden says the
following by the term cult I mean
nothing derogatory to any group so
classified a cult as I Define it is any
religious group which differ
significantly in one or more respects as
to belief or practice from those
religious groups which are regarded as
the normative expressions of religion in
our total culture
I may add to this that a cult might also
be defined as a group of people gathered
about a specific person or person's
interpretation of the
Bible for
example Jehovah's Witnesses are for the
most part followers of the
interpretations of Charles T Russell and
JF
Rutherford although founder Russell and
his successor Rutherford are long since
dead Jehovah's Witnesses today still
look to the watchtowers organ the
Watchtower organization and its
governing body to understand the
Bible in fact Jehovah's Witnesses are
taught that they cannot understand the
Bible without the organization
explaining it to
them close
quote this is the definition I have
utilized in the past as well the term
cult is not being used for the sake of
being derogatory or nasty but for
specificities sake
a cult is a group that claims to be a
part of the whole in this case
Christianity but they deny one or more
of the fundamental biblical foundational
aspects of the Christian
religion and Walter added that they also
tend to be rallied around a specific
person's misinterpretations of the
Bible teaching that one can't really
understand the Bible without this
individual
well the Adventist Church absolutely
fits the bill for Martin's additional
claim as can very plainly be seen in
their statement of confidence in the
writings of Ellen G white where they
tell us that her writings uplift the
normative character of scripture and
correct inaccurate interpretations of
it uplifting the normative character of
scripture is just another way of saying
that without them you can't really know
what the Bible is
saying you need her and her infallible
interpretation and this is why when he
was invited onto the John Ankerberg Show
after the publishing of the kingdom of
the Colts and he discussed with William
Johnson who was the representative from
the SDA Church Martin's Focus was on the
authority of Ellen White within
adventism he obviously came across
information that he wasn't privy to when
doing his investigation the internet did
not exist in his day for him to Simply
bring up what we just
saw but tonight we're going to be
focusing on the former half of that
definition about doctrine that departs
from
Orthodoxy and we are going to see if
they strike out on both parts of
Martin's working definition so that is
some of the background on questions on
Doctrine the goal was to present advinus
theology in such a way that sounded in
line with Biblical Christian Orthodoxy
where they softened or in some cases
reinterpreted some of their more
controversial doctrines like the
investigative judgment and the nature of
Christ and while this helped Adventists
gain more acceptance from evangelicals
it also sparked a lot of internal
controversy many Adventists felt like it
compromised core teachings and it led to
a deep division within the denomination
that still lingers to this day so since
the goal of questions on Doctrine was to
try and present problematic adven
teachings in such a way that an
Evangelical wouldn't be suspicious of it
makes it the perfect example for us to
look at to see how they do this with
Michael the
Archangel afterward I will show you how
they are veiling the full belief and the
larger role that this plays in the
Adventist system of theology where we
will look at a span of 70 years worth of
claims
70 years folks that's almost half the
lifetime of this short
movement and we will see if it fits the
definition of a
cult so question eight from the book
reads as follows
quote it has been charged this is the
question it has been charged that
seventh day Adventists hold the same
belief as do the Jehovah's Witnesses
concerning Michael that Michael the
Archangel was Jesus Christ prior to his
incarnation
and that he was a created
being is this accusation
valid if Michael is Christ how do you
explain Jude
nine they then respond to the question
or begin the
response we emphatically reject the idea
set forth in this question and the
position held by the Jehovah's Witnesses
we do not believe that Christ is a
created being we as a people have not
considered the identification of Michael
of sufficient prominence to dwell upon
uh to dwell upon it at Great length in
uh either in our literature or in our
preaching but we do have clear views on
the subject and are prepared to set them
forth and our views concerning Michael
it might be added have been held by
various eminent Scholars through the
centuries we are therefore not alone in
our understanding we believe that the
term Michael is but one of the many
titles applied to the Son of God the
second person of the godhead but such a
view does not in any way conflict with
our belief in his full deity and eternal
pre-existence nor does it in the least
disparage his person and
work close
quote so the positioning of the question
is from the framework of the Jehovah's
Witnesses
and if the SDA belief is the same the
answer they give which goes on Beyond
this focuses on
that and no they don't teach the same
thing as the Jehovah's Witnesses namely
that Jesus is a created Angelic
being at least by this point they did
not
however understand that early on some of
the SDA Pioneers did teach that Jesus
was a created being just like the
Jehovah's Witnesses such as Uriah Smith
in his book thoughts critical and
practical on the Book of Revelation
which is from
1865 where he writes
quote these things saith the
amen this is then the final message to
the churches uh air the close of
Probation and though the description he
gives to the indifferent leod deans of
their condition is fearful and startling
nevertheless it cannot be denied
for the witness is faithful and true
moreover he is the beginning of the
creation of
God not the beginner but the beginning
of the creation the first created being
dating his existence far back before any
other created being or thing next to the
self-existent and eternal God close
quote so yes they were indeed teaching
at one point
that Jesus was a created being first
created being just like the Jehovah's
Witnesses even if they had pivoted off
of such belief by the time questions on
Doctrine was being
published some of the Pioneers were
full-blown Aryans like Smith others were
semiarians
but they were supposedly the Commandment
keeping Church raised up in the last
days to restore the true church
Apostolic Christianity
restored teaching Aryan heresy an idol
violating the first commandment some of
the clearest evidence that this is not
true but this is why you have multiple
camps within present day 7th Day
adventism and there's a growing Push by
some of them to go back to the Pioneers
in this
area but back to questions on
Doctrine included in the
question is if they teach that Michael
the Archangel was Jesus
Christ prior to his incarn
as a
man to which the first the first
sentence says they emphatically reject
the idea set forth in this question
which is
slippery and you will see why because
the question includes more than just the
idea that their belief is an identical
onetoone with the Jehovah's Witnesses
but they chose to focus their answer on
making sure that they emphasized what is
true that they don't teach the same
thing as the Jehovah's Witnesses
thinking that if they demonstrated this
well then they're in the clear and their
teaching in this area isn't
cultic nice try but stick
around
secondly notice how they
claim that they as a people have not
considered the identification of Michael
of significant prominence to dwell upon
at length either in their PR literature
or
preaching so remember that that's
two
thirdly you see the claim that their
view has been held by various eminent
Scholars through the
centuries it's what they told us later
on in that later paragraph
this is the other approach you will hear
some of them take that they're not alone
in their View and people like some of
the Protestant reformers believe the
same thing this is supposed to be one of
those things where they are trying to
add theological Street credit to their
belief and imply that if you take
umbrage with their view in this area
then you have to take umage with all
those people
too so that's three
fourthly notice how they say well
actually I need to I guess go back to
this
one notice how they say the name Michael
is but one of many names applied to the
Son of
God and they make sure to include that
he is a part of the godhead has full
deity Eternal
pre-existence seeking to convey that the
name Michael is more or less one name
among many that's just applied to Jesus
it just signifies he's head of the
Angels like we heard David asri say in
that intro clip just a name to convey a
title or
role then lastly they finished that
section by saying that their belief
about Michael in no way disparages
Jesus's person or his
work I'm going to say that again they
say that they're teaching on Jesus being
Michael in no way disparages the person
and work of Christ
so to summarize remember these
claims was Michael the
Archangel Jesus prior to his
Incarnation they don't explicitly deny
this but they make it sound like they do
to to this point
1857 they didn't dwell upon this subject
at length either in their printed
literature or
preaching three their view has been held
by lots of well-respected Christian
Scholars which is supposed to lower your
guard on their
teaching four the name Michael is just
one of many names applied to the Son of
God and
five their Doctrine in this area in no
way disparages the person and work
of
Jesus so remember these Central claims
tonight I will periodically be
referencing back to them because this is
the summation of what you can plan to
hear from lots of Adventists including
present-- day
leaders whether they are aware of it or
not they have simply inherited the
defenses that that are put forth in that
book I also want to remind you that this
was published in
1857 that will become important with
regards to the claim that this subject
was never a point upon which they spent
a great deal in their
literature as we will see it is true
they do not hold the same view as the
Jehovah's Witnesses and I'm sure the
folks behind this book loved that the
question was focused upon that because
it allowed them to then Focus their
answer upon
that and that if they don't believe
identically to the witnesses
specifically to the idea that Jesus is a
created angelic being well then that
gets them off the
hook but with that said we're now going
to begin looking at a large volume of
sources from their own printed
literature the same literature that the
book tells us they didn't spend a lot of
time discussing we're going to begin in
1885 and we're going to work our way all
the way up to
1954 a mere three years before the
publishing of questions on Doctrine a
spectrum of almost 70 years worth of
quotes
coming from the SDA Church's own
Publications periodically we're going to
look at Ellen White along the way
okay beginning in 1885 in the April 21st
issue of review and Herald they
published a a short section titled the
Archangel and it poses a number of
questions followed by six points but
notice five
quote the question was who is the
Archangel answer Michael the proof Jude
n who is Michael answer the Lord Jesus
Christ proof one Michael is a prince
then they list out their proof text
Daniel 10:13 and 21 so is Christ Daniel
9:25 acts 3:16 and
531 and then answer five bullet point
five that they give Michael was an angel
a chief Angel Archangel so was Christ
Exodus 23:20 and 21 the angel that went
before Israel had God's name in him and
the power to Pardon transgressions
Christ has his father's name Isaiah 9:6
and Hebrews 1:8 and the power to forgive
sins Mark 2:10 the Apostle says in 1
Corinthians 10:9 that some in the
wilderness tempted Christ and were
destroyed was not this the angel with
God's name whom the people were warned
not to provoke because he would not
pardon their transgressions Exodus
23:21 close
quote so here they very clearly called
Jesus an angel to which Adventists are
going to AR argue this isn't saying he's
an angel like the created angels the
word Angel is being used to refer to a
role here that as Archangel he's the
leader of the Angels but he isn't an
Angelic being with an Angelic
nature we also see their equation with
the angel of the Lord in the Old
Testament with Michael I've talked about
this elsewhere and shown how this is
fallacious we'll get into some of that
later but these are two totally
different figures the angel of the Lord
in the Old Testament is indeed Yahweh
the almighty God they are right when
they point out that he is worshiped and
he forgives sins something that only the
almighty God can do according to
scripture but the angel of the Lord is
not Michael but the point being this is
the first instance that I could find
where they mention Michael in their
Publications and within the teaching
Jesus is indeed called an angel so let's
see if they continue to expound upon
this more as we move along
moving forward to the October 29 1896
issue of signs of the times another
official publication of the SDA Church
they published an article titled the
controversy of the
Ages which is a part of a larger series
of
articles in number four of that series
they talk about Michael and give further
clarification around what they mean that
Jesus is an Angel and the role this
plays within the great controversy par
Paradigm and storyline
quote preeminently he who afterward
became Jesus had been declared to be the
Son of God before the world was he was
one with the father possessing Glory
with the Father John 175 of the very
image of his father's substance Hebrews
1:3 but his claim to the Eternal sunship
and equality in counsel and work and
honor had been disputed by that being
who stood next to the son
the one above all others who in himself
sealed up the sum of all created wisdom
and Beauty Ezekiel
28:12 he not only disputed the right of
the word of God to his position but he
led others to do the same and a third of
Heaven's spirits of light revolted the
universe became divided by the entrance
of
sin so before
proceeding this is the
proof that their view is not the same as
the Jehovah's
Witnesses but that does not get them off
the hook there are other potential
ditches that they can fall into and they
do make sure you catch the difference
that we're about to see but also
remember that less than 30 years before
this people like Uriah smith top
teachers and leaders in the movement
were indeed teaching that Jesus was the
first created being of the Eternal God
by this point they had
pivoted however you'll also see here the
spin that they try to give to Ellen
White's claiming Jesus was exalted to be
made equal with God the father in the
pre-earth existence of
Heaven Satan was supposedly next to the
Son of God and Authority something
scripture nowhere claims or teaches
folks Jesus is Yahweh the almighty we're
going to get into that later as well
Satan's Creator and judge but go and
read Spirit of Prophecy volume 1
beginning on page 17 and you'll see how
what this paragraph is saying is being
altered Spirit of prophecies from
1858 alen was claiming that Lucifer
became jealous of Jesus after he was
exalted to be made equal with God the
father and was given an authority that
he didn't previously have as well as
access to counsels that he wasn't
previously brought
into that's what triggered Lucifer
becoming Satan supposedly leading to him
being jealous that this wasn't done to
him and starting the Great controversy
or war against God and His law yet here
in 1896 they're trying to claim nothing
ever changed about Jesus Lucifer just
started disputing what had always been
the case and this is what started the
controversy which is the modern defense
that you're going to hear from them on
this to this day I hear it all the time
which is why I always use Spirit of
Prophecy volume one beginning on page 17
when discussing this because they're
engaging in what is called anacron is M
where you read back into the past
something from your present vantage
point they try and read back into
Ellen's 1858 writings their post 1890
christology even though Scholars like
Jerry moon are on record admitting that
the post 1890 view is different than the
early
teachings you have to remember that by
the 1890s the movement had pivoted off
of its Aryan roots with the help of
Ellen White Vision supposedly confirming
the new direction that they would go
in Desire of Ages was published in the
1890s and that's when their historians
and Scholars claim that they finally got
the Trinity right and embraced a
trinitarian concept we've looked at all
of that exhaustively before if you're
curious on that the link will be in the
description box down below but moving
forward
quote but the doubts of Satan and his M
madans did not affect the fact of the
sunship of the word
he was the Eternal Son of God still to
him the father said let us make Etc his
omnipotent power his Divine Majesty
might have been Vindicated when Lucifer
rebelled by the instant destruction of
all the rebel
host but such a course would have swn
doubts in the minds of beings who were
on probation but were yet
loyal neither was it God's power that
was alone called in question question
but God's character meaning the Ten
Commandments of the law it is that which
the adversary has persistently and
unremittingly assailed from the
beginning of sin if God's creatures
could be led to believe that God is not
love that he's unjust partial implacable
unmerciful they will not serve him they
fall in easy prey to
Satan close
quote so before moving forward
make sure you're following along with
what is being said here the revisionism
of the original claims about Jesus being
exalted put aside they say that God
would have uh could have just destroyed
Satan immediately upon his
Rebellion but this would have
communicated to all the other angels and
beings on other worlds that Satan was
right in his charges against God and his
character that he's a tyrant Etc that
would have only further soed doubts in
the minds of the angels that were on a
probation
period so this is the SDA Church's
answer to the question and problem of
evil what is called theodicy in
Christian theology the problem of evil
why does evil exist if God is good
Etc I can't tell you how many Adventists
reach out to us and tell me that the
reason they Embrace this great
controversy storyline is because they
personally feel like it provides the
best solution to the problem of evil but
nevertheless what I is the building
blocks of their Central claim that God
and His law are on trial because of
these pre-earth accusations from Satan
and now he's vindicating both himself
and his law from those
accusations which as I've shown numerous
times before is what they claim is the
Central purpose of their understanding
of the Gospel the Vindication of God
from the accusations of Satan so make
sure you're following along with the
flow here now this article moves to the
next section which has the subheading of
efforts to save efforts to
save
quote for the reasons that God is
merciful loving kind just he did not
destroy Lucifer and the rebellious hosts
he gave him and them the opportunity to
repent and
turn he pleaded with them as only God
could plead to restore them to
righteousness and
life how do we know this yeah great
question
we know it because it is thus that God
pleads now and he is eternally the
same with whom is no variableness nor
shadow of turning the Son of God did not
aspire to be equal with God did not
meditate a usurpation to the throne of
the universe while Li saw uh Lucifer
plotting for Eternal Dominion I should
say he sorry while he saw Lucifer
plotting for Eternal Dominion
Philippians 2
5-7 but he emptied himself gave himself
then and there for
Sinners he took the form of a
servant became an angel among the
angels that he might redeem Angels but
they would
not and when they rejected the
righteousness and life so freely offered
he came lower still to those duped by
Satan Fallen men stooping even to death
that he might redeem the Fallen who wish
to be redeemed and vindicate to the
universe to all eternity the character
of
God that was the work of the Son of God
the Eternal logos when he became Michael
when he became Jesus the man of Nazareth
when he was anointed the
Christ when he died our sacrifice on
Calvary and during all this time all the
host of evil with all the baleful
deception cruel devices of
sin were brought against him that God's
character might be marred that the great
Vindicator might
fail close
quote
wow catch
that for
starters notice we see Philippians 2
being appealed to to support this keep a
mental note on
that but what you heard word is supposed
to be about something taking place prior
to the Earth even
existing this is in their pre-earth
narrative since God is merciful they say
that he gave an opportunity to repent to
the angels that fell with Satan he
pleaded with them as only God
could and they claimed that we can know
this because God is immutable and
doesn't
change since he's merciful that has to
mean that he pleaded with the angels to
repent and he gave them opportunity for
such but how did God do this pleading
supposedly well just like Jesus came to
Earth to plead for the reconciliation of
Fallen man he did the same thing with
the
angels before incarnating as a man he
took the form of a servant as an angel
that he might redeem the Angels but they
would not
and not a single one of them took Jesus
up on his pleading and his
offer and it was after this pleading
with the angels as an angel that Jesus
then sunk even
lower down to Fallen humans taking on a
human nature to do the same thing on our
plane and both of these Incarnation
events as an angel and as a human were
to ultimately do
what vindicate God from Satan's
accusations which is what they claim as
I've shown in other Publications is the
core of the gospel for them God
vindicating himself from Satan's
accusations which
means this teaching around Michael is
not at all secondary
folks it is integral to the entire
Paradigm in order for their God to be
Vindicated they're Gods as we're going
to see Jesus had to prove to both
classes of Fallen creatures humans and
angels that Satan is a
liar the law can be kept it's fair it
can't change
Etc remember how one of the points in
questions on Doctrine was that the the
name Michael simply one of the many for
Jesus and it really doesn't go beyond
that no that's not
true here they claim that he became
Michael the Archangel when he was sent
on a mission to try and save the
apostate Angels who all rejected him by
becoming an angel
himself and in a little bit you're going
to see that they expound upon this
identical article further where they
reward some things and it gets even
worse
this fiction is not compatible with the
scriptures folks Jesus never became an
angel to try and save Angels God being
merciful does not prove this this is
whole cloth fiction from their pre-earth
origin narrative which is not coming
from scripture it's coming from Ellen
White Hebrews 2 is clear Jesus came to
save The Offspring of Abraham that's
human
beings it explicitly says he doesn't
help Angels but the spring of
Abraham notice the tail end of Hebrews
TW of Hebrews
2 the whole chapter is about Jesus being
superior to the angels and better than
them but at the end of the chapter the
author cites from the Old Testament and
explains how Jesus wasn't ashamed to
call us his brother because this was
foretold in the Old
Testament in bringing many sons and
daughters to Glory humans verse 10 Jesus
was not ashamed to share in flesh and
blood with us to make that a
reality aka the Incarnation was foretold
in the Old Testament but more
specifically notice verse
16 for surely It's Not Angels he helps
but Abraham's
descendants for this reason he had to be
made like them fully human in every way
in order that he might become a merciful
and faithful high priest in the service
of God and that he might make atonement
for the sins of the
people furthermore it's ironic that the
SDA Church will appeal to Jude n
regarding the claim that it proves Jesus
as Michael when Jude 6 tells us the
Angels who didn't keep their positions
of authority but abandon their proper
dwelling these he has kept in darkness
bound with Everlasting chains for
judgment on the great day
which lets us know that their fate was
sealed upon
Rebellion unlike humans Angels had full
knowledge of God's glory and they still
chose to Rebel making their fault
irreversible and again in second Peter
2 specifically verse four Peter is
explaining here how false teachers would
creep into the
church teaching destructive heresies he
goes on later in the chapter to explain
that he's about to be taken to his death
his martyrdom
and so he's writing this to leave them
with his final words and he warns them
there's going to be false teachers that
creep in here and they're going to be
teaching destructive heresies like great
controversy
theology but within the flow of that
Peter explains how God will eventually
judge these
deceivers but before explaining that he
gives examples to support this claim
where he refers to other instances where
God did exactly
this and he starts by pointing to the
fallen angels as an
example their High status dignity even
their pre Fallen Holiness it didn't stop
them from being cast into
hell so his point is if God dealt with
them harshly then false teachers have no
chance of escaping judgment either
that's his point but what does he tell
us about the angels that
fell that God did not spare them when
they sinned but cast them into hell
committing them to chains of gloomy
Darkness to be kept until
judgment catch
that they sinned and were
committed
committed to
chains bondage bound up in darkness
until the day of
judgment they're in the equivalent of
jail awaiting their sentencing to to
then be cast into Eternal
prison totally consistent with Jude and
not at all compatible with this great
controversy fiction
furthermore Jesus himself tells us in
Matthew
25:41 that the Eternal fires of hell
were prepared for Satan and his angels
this would be rather bizarre for Jesus
to say unless hell was prepared between
him becoming an angel and then becoming
a
man because if it was prepared for
Satan and the
angels it would make no sense that Jesus
would then become one to try and save
them after preparing hell for
them nevertheless three strikes and
you're out Hebrews Jude and second Peter
all refute this false
teaching so God did not seek to help and
save Angels sending Jesus who took on
the nature of an Angel to plead with
them and try and save them but every
single one of them rejected him so then
he sunk even lower down to humans to try
and save them and if you think that's
not what's being claimed here buckle up
as I will show you this wording
verbatim that in the controversy between
Jesus and Satan Jesus went to the angels
as an angel himself among the Angels
possessing their Natures to prove that
Satan is a liar the law can be kept
angels can do it Etc but I will save my
other thoughts for that when we uh you
know get to expounding upon this more
we're we're only two two sources in so
buckle up it's going to be a long
night moving ahead to the March 19 1902
issue of signs of the times in this
issue there's an article titled the
measure of God's
love which is telling the reader about
all about how much the Son of God loves
them followed by outlining the steps
that Jesus Took to show that love within
that they speak of him as Michael the
Archangel and how just like he showed
this love to humans through the
Incarnation so too he did with the
angels
quote God's purpose in Christ Jesus was
a perfect one in the beginning What
followed in the humiliation of his son
were but steps in the Eternal purpose
and revealings of that love adapted to
the understanding and apprehension of
the sin blinded minds of his creatures
meaning angels and
humans note the successive steps as
revealed by the
Apostle who being originally in the form
of God counted it not a thing to be
grasped to be on an equality with God
but emptied himself taking the form of a
bonder servant becoming in the likeness
of men and being found in fashion as a
man he humbled himself becoming obedient
even unto death yay the death of the
Cross Philippians 2
6-8 so pause again before moving forward
notice again the abuse of Philippians
2 in every single one of these quotes
they're using this as a proof text to
support the notion that prior to
incarnating as a man the Son of God
supposedly incarnated as an angel on the
plane of angels to seek and save Angels
no differently than he did with
Humanity I have shown this
before this is from the SDA Church's own
website presently on article talking
about their teaching on Jesus's life
death and
Resurrection notice they claim to teach
that Jesus is 100% man and 100% God
what's called the hypothetic Union in
Christian theology they even bold it to
make sure you really see it and it
stands out this is all lip service and
the evidence for such is in the bottom
paragraph where only a few sentences
later we see Philippians 2 mentioned and
it says the same thing these articles
have been saying regarding Jesus setting
aside his
divinity they say that even though he
was God he set his divine nature aside
and took on human
nature for those that do not know this
is what's called the kosis
interpretation of this text and it is a
heresy that is not what Paul is claiming
here Paul is using Christ humbling
himself as a man as an example for us to
serve one another that's the context and
he explains how Christ being God did not
have to do or um yeah he explains how
Christ being God did not have to do that
he did not have to Humble himself under
the law Galatians
4:4 and suffer at the hands of Sinners
bearing our
iniquities but he freely chose to do
this he set aside that rightful status
and he humbled himself to suffer for our
sakes therefore as his followers we
should imitate that and not think to
highly of ourselves but humbly serve one
another this will give rise to all sorts
of AVST complaining but so be it notice
what Augustine points out in this text
in his commentary on Philippians yes
Adventist I know he isn't infallible
that's not the point just listen to what
he
explains I'm so beyond the adventis
Bible onlyism this nonsense they try to
equate as solos scriptura now solos
scriptura doesn't mean you just
completely attach the Bible from
everyone that came before us Augustine
holds for for Protestants actual
classical Protestants Augustine holds
what holds what's called ministerial
Authority yes he's an authority he's not
infallible but that doesn't mean he's
not an authority you need to consult
these individuals but he what he says
here comports perfectly with the context
notice what he says
quote commenting on Philippians 2:7 he
said to have emptied himself in no other
way than by taking the form of a servant
not by losing the form of God for that
nature by which he's equal to the father
in the form of God remained immutable
while he took our mutable nature through
which he was born of the Virgin he did
not take on his Humanity in the simple
way that a person puts on clothes as
something exterior to him rather he took
on human form in a manner inexpressibly
more excellent and more intimate than
that
the Apostle has made it sufficiently
clear what he meant he was made to
appear in human likeness he was not
exhaustively reduced to being a man he
rather assumed the true human estate
when he put on the man close
quote exactly
correct there has been virtually zero
disagreement on this in the entire life
of the New Testament church across the
board regarding less of theological
tradition the kosis interpretation is a
modernist one that goes back to Godfrey
tasus and other German theologians in
the 19th
century and it was picked up by
sectarian groups like The Seventh Day
Adventist because it fits with their
framework and in the SDA case you're
seeing how the kinosis interpretation is
not compatible with the hypostatic Union
which is why I said it's just lip
service on their website or they're
confused or or something because that's
a big part of why it hasn't become
accepted Christian interpretation
without creating serious christological
heresy but back to the quote and
specifically the context of Michael how
does all of this support Jesus as
Michael the Archangel when Philippians 2
says nothing about
that folks that's the proof that they're
saying that what Jesus did on Earth by
incarnating as a man and taking on a
human nature he did identically so only
to the angels meaning he added unto
himself an Angelic Nature by becoming an
angel and setting his divinity
aside which is what they outright go on
to say and why they use Philippians 2 to
try and support this as being Biblical
quote the first thing was the unselfish
Divine Purpose of emptying himself which
included all the sacrifice for the
Redemption of the lost the fruitage of
infinite
love the first
step the first step was The Taking of
the form of a bonder
servant with no will but his Masters to
serve and not to rule we Behold Him thus
as an angel with the
angels He was Michael the Archangel
Chief only because he was the chief
servant of God the most devoted of all
he partook of their nature and his
Angelic Ministry
may be traced from the time that sin
entered throughout the record of the Old
Testament the Second
Step the second step in the
manifestation of the purpose was
becoming in the likeness of
men Those whom sin had made lower than
the
angels He took the form to retain it
forever he will never be in outward form
form what he was in the
beginning he gave up all the ineffable
glory of the godlikeness for man's sake
he lived for man suffered for man died
for man and will ever bear the prince of
the scars forever glorified which sin
made the sacrifice was
eternal close
quote Mercy
this is a different Jesus a Jesus that
became an Angel With An Angel Nature by
taking on the name Michael and this was
the first step in the process of
humiliation they
claim and before moving to the Second
Step which included sinking even lower
and incarnating as a man to try and save
humans
too so in Christian theology the term
humiliation is not a negative term
it is referring to the Incarnation of
Christ God condescending down to us to
save
us so again they're claiming that the
Adventist Jesus before coming to the
Earth to save humans as a man himself
sunk down by becoming an
angel his name in doing this was Michael
the head of the Angels only because
because he was the chief servant of God
more devoted than
all he partook of their nature
and engaged in Angelic
Ministry which can be traced from the
time that sin entered throughout the
record of the Old
Testament so that
means that when Lucifer rebelled and
became Satan the adversary and after God
held his council meeting to determine
the solution that would be carried out
in this
problem part of that included Jesus
becoming an angel to try and save the
apostle at angels that was step one of
Christ's humiliation they're
claiming but all the Angels rejected him
every single one of
them and he was seeking to do this from
the time of Satan's sinning throughout
the Old
Testament in which case they point to
the angel of the Lord to try and claim
that figure is synonymous with
Michael the Second Step then included
him sinking even lower down to our level
where he took on the nature of a man and
that nature he will retain
forever so he just gave up the angel
nature he becomes an angel setting his
divinity
aside but then you're going to see a
quote later where they say well he was
God with the angels so he was God as an
angel but then he gives up his Angelic
nature to become a man but then he'll
remain a man
forever but notice what they all
said in taking on the form of humanity
he will never again be in the outward
form like he was in the
beginning he gave up all the ineffable
glory of the godlikeness for man's sake
and this sacrifice was
eternal meaning they are saying that
something Jesus had prior to
incarnating he'll never get back
what you will see referred to throughout
Ellen White's writings as his eternal
humiliation for example notice Ellen
White in Desire of Ages page 48
quote it would have been an almost
infinite humiliation for the Son of God
to take man's
nature even when Adam stood in his
innocence in
Eden but Jesus accepted Humanity when
the race had been weakened by 4,000
years of sin like every child of Adam he
accepted the results of the working of
the Great Law of
heredity what these results were is
shows uh in the history of his Earthly
ancestors he came with such a heredity
to share our sorrows and temptations and
to give us the example of a sinless life
close
quote and this is all the evidence one
needs to understand that the SDA system
of theology doesn't understand what it
means that Jesus is the second
Adam he's not in the Fallen posterity of
the first adom like the rest of us this
is part of why the Virgin birth is a
cardinal doctrine of the Christian faith
but without rabbit trailing off you know
other aspects of their errant
understanding of Jesus's human nature
this is an example of where this idea
regarding infinite humiliation is coming
from that upon assuming a human nature
Jesus forever sacrificed things that he
had prior to doing such and will never
get those
back
folks the humiliation of Christ ended
after the resurrection and his
Ascension yes he will retain his human
nature forever he will forever be the
God
man but he did not set his divinity
aside in the Incarnation or lose Divine
attributes
forever he simply added unto himself
true human
nature when we look at the full spectrum
of what Jesus did we see that Christ was
in his lofty
Abode he then sinks down to our
level adds unto himself a human nature
to experience his Creation With Us
reconciling the world to himself by
suffering at the hands of Sinners
thinking to the lowest regions Possible
only to then rise and go back to where
he was in
glory he comes down to go right back
up and the Transfiguration is only a
small glimpse that Jesus lost zero of
his Divine Glory attribution Etc upon
incarnating his flesh simply veiled That
Glory for a season it's like if he
walked down the street in all his glory
before Sinners they would have fallen
over
dead so his flesh for a season veiled
That
Glory but once he returned to his throne
at the Ascension That Glory is no longer
veiled and includes his glorified human
body which we will also share in one
day now of course I have to show the
receipts on this because it will be said
that I'm lying I'm misrepresenting
stating my own opinion Etc notice the
fundamental beliefs book which is the
official exposition of their 28
fundamental beliefs on the belief about
Jesus they write
quote Jesus asserted his omnipresence
with the assurances Lo I'm with you
always even to the End of the Age
Matthew 28:20 and where two or three are
gathered together in my name I am there
in the midst of them Matthew
18:20 although his divinity has the
natural ability of
omnipresence the Incarnate Christ has
voluntarily limited himself in this
respect he's chosen to be omnipresent
through the Ministry of the Holy Spirit
John 141
16-18 close
quote they openly claim that while his
divinity has the natural ability of
omnipresence the Incarnate Christ has
voluntarily limited himself in this
respect and has chosen to be omnipresent
through the means of the Holy
Spirit well what did we just read in
signs of the times regarding Christ's
Humanity
they said he will forever retain his
Humanity as a part of the Eternal
sacrifice that he
made which means he will never regain
truly being
omnipresent because they are yielding to
Ellen White's claims here not John 14
John 14 doesn't say anything about Jesus
not being omnipresent upon incarnating
and that he set this aside it's where
Jesus is explaining that the holy spirit
will be sent to the church and poured
out at Pentecost nothing about Jesus
nature or
ontology but this is what they are
paraphrasing Ellen White Desire of Ages
page 669
quote the holy spirit is Christ
representative but divested of the
personality of humanity and independent
thereof cumbered with
Humanity Christ could not be in every
place
personally therefore it was for their
interest that he should go to the father
and send the spirit to be his successor
on Earth no one could then have any
advantage because of his location or his
personal contact with Christ by the
spirit the Savior would be accessible to
All in This sense he would be nearer to
them than if he had not ascended on high
close
quote and this shows why terms
matter for those in the know you'll know
what they mean when they use the term
person which is someone's physical
tangible
form so since Christ is cumbered with
Humanity he can't be omnipresent she
says but the Holy Spirit isn't therefore
can can be omnipresent so that's how
Christ has chosen to be
such for those that want to see a
plethora of biblical proof that Jesus is
indeed omnipresent while incarnate never
set this aside and demonstrated as much
in his ministry check out this article
on our website where I go into a number
of examples and also link to all of the
SDA Source documentation on this so you
can check it out for yourself the link
is in the description box down
below but folks this ain't the
Trinity this is not the one true God
that has revealed himself to us in the
Incarnation and scripture there is no
salvaging this and I wish the SDA Church
would just be forthright about that and
not try and act like those of us who are
critical can't read that we're
misrepresenting things it's Etc all of
this tonight has been Crystal Clear
nothing's being
misrepresented anyone that just cares
about the truth can see
that this is a very different Jesus than
the Jesus of the Bible and you can't be
the alleged commandment keeping church
when you have an idol codified in your
teaching
documents including the exposition of
your own fundamental beliefs not some
pre1 1900s document or
something this is also insight for you
Christian that this organization does
not use basic words like God Divinity
Etc the same way that we
do they'll say Jesus is God and in the
next breath they'll say he set his
divinity aside and permanently
permanently lost
omnipresence same with words like person
and personality of
humanity but just to recap so far they
are consistently teaching over the
course of multiple decades
that it was necessary for God to
vindicate his character from accusations
that Satan made which SED seeds of Doubt
amongst the
Angels this put God in a bind because if
he would have just extinguished Satan
then and there it would have
communicated to the angels that Satan
was right God is a tyrant So the plan of
action that God the father and the son
came up with was that Satan would be
permitted to
exist the seeds that he SED would
grow and God would vindicate himself
along with his character I.E the law
through demonstrating that he truly is
loving
Etc and this involved Jesus taking on
the nature of an Angel becoming Michael
the Archangel where he sought to try and
save apostate angels that rebelled with
Satan but not a single one of them
accepted the gift that was
offered while on that plane of angels as
an angel Michael kept the law perfectly
as an angel showing that it can be done
which also silenced Satan's accusation
that angels can keep the LA can't keep
the law it needs to change
Etc this was taking place from the time
that Satan sinned and throughout the Old
Testament period as we're going to see
later they say for 4,000 years Jesus was
an angel
after that was complete Jesus then moved
on to the second step in Sinking even
lower this time down to humans where he
incarnated as a man and he'll retain
that nature
forever in doing this he eternally
surrendered certain things that he had
prior to doing so such as his
omnipresence and this was all to
demonstrate that God is love which is
the exact thing they say the Great
controversy is over the law which is a
transcript of God's
character this is abject heresy there's
no spin that can make this biblical no
amount of proof texting and twisting of
the Bible is going to prove that this is
the one true God the Triune God of both
scripture and
reality this is demonic Doctrine veiled
behind trying to make you focus on how
sweet and loving the idol
sounds but at the end of the day it's
still an idol
remember questions on Doctrine they
emphatically
asserted what we teach in this in this
regard no no way diminishes or degrades
the work of
Christ yes it
does when you add things to the work of
Christ and claim that he did stuff he
didn't do you entirely warp the work of
Christ you attribute false things to him
that he did not do
what if I said all Adventists are are
serial
killers yeah you wouldn't like that
being attributed to
you claiming Jesus did things he didn't
actually do is not
loving furthermore in the case of what
they're claiming regarding
Michael it results in talking about a
completely different figure than the god
of the Bible resulting in an
idol so no this is not secondary this is
not me making a big deal out of nothing
this is dangerous teaching Adventist
need warned about this and until this
organization is ready to go on record
and denounce this as
heresy well it's safe to assume they
still stand behind
this we're just getting started we're
three sources in it's G to be a long
night folks it's gonna be about three
more hours probably buckle up it gets
worse it gets worse we're just setting
the ground
still seriously buckle
up they will not be able to distance
themselves from this because as you're
going to see this is intimately
connected with the larger Claim about
God's character being
Vindicated which like I've shown before
they say is the central core of their
whole message the Vindication of God's
character I also want to point out that
Ellen White was alive during all these
statements thus far she died in 1915 and
as we will see later part of her role is
to be the protector from doctrinal
error but there is no weaseling out of
this there's no weaseling out of this
okay moving ahead to the May 11 1904
issue of signs of the
times in this issue we're given even
more details about the comprehensiveness
of this teaching in the bigger great
controversy storyline in
Paradigm they have an article titled A A
tried Stone where they talk about the
testing trials and temptations that the
Son of God experienced in both
incarnating as an angel and as a
man this is a consistent parallel that
you'll see them making that what he did
on one plane he also did on the other
both as an angel and as a man only an
angel he didn't die like he did when he
incarnated as a
human this article has three subheadings
titled the first test the second test
and the third
test in the first test they claimed
Jesus was tested as creator that
creation itself was a test of his power
and he passed that test with flying
colors with no
failure but here's what they write about
the second
test this is the whole whole section and
it didn't take that long
quote Christ being the Son of God and
being associated in all that perit uh
pertain to the the position was God the
word that was made flesh was God John
1114 or one uh
11114 and the father calls him God in
Hebrews 1:9 but in passing from the
bosom of the father to the nature of man
he did not come the whole way at One
Stop he did not come the whole way at
One
Stop he first became an angel and was
tried or tested in that
capacity in delivering Israel from Egypt
the Lord went before them in a pillar of
cloud Exodus 13:21 and he was the angel
of God Exodus
14:19 God told the people that he would
send his Angel before them to keep them
in the way he was one of whom God said
my name is in him and he was one who
could for for sins Exodus
23 he's also called the presence of God
Exodus 33 amid the angel of his presence
Isaiah
63 as an angel he successfully delivered
the people from bondage overcoming their
enemies when the natural sources of
water failed he brought water from a
rock when food failed he fed them with
bread from Heaven 40
years so successful was his career as
angel that he was the chief or ar
Angel close
quote so remember they conflate the
angel of the Lord or the angel of his
presence who is found in the Old
Testament with Michael this is false we
will look at why in a
moment but remember what else we've read
the term Angels not just referring to
the role of messenger or head of the
Angels it is tied to having an Angelic
nature and there saying that the Son of
God endured various tests before he
passed from the bosom of the father to
taking on human nature he first became
an angel and was tested as an
angel and when they read about the angel
of the Lord in the Old Testament they're
then seeing this as Jesus being tested
as an angel where he did various things
like delivering Israel from Egypt going
before the people in a pillar of cloud
Etc
since as an angel he successfully
delivered the Israelites from bondage
brought water forth from the rock um
when there was none gave them food from
heaven when they had none all of this
was part of his career as an angel his
Angelic
Ministry supposedly demonstrating to
them who God is in the controversy with
Satan these were acts of God as an angel
whatever that's supposed to mean
demonstrating to Angels that God is love
Satan is a liar
Etc that's the larger role of these
Feats that they're supposed to play in
the great controversy
worldview now with regards to the
confusing of Michael with the angel of
the
Lord notice questions on Doctrine again
they present their argument for this in
there and this is the argument you're
going to still hear
today from the same question as earlier
question number eight they write
quote the use of the expression the Lord
rebuke thee is significant it's found in
but one other place in the Holy
scriptures Zechariah
3:2 there the speaker is the Angel of
the Lord verse one but in verse two it
is expressly the Lord who
speaks here we find the angel of the
Lord equated with Jehovah himself and it
is he who says to Satan the Lord rebuke
thee this is a unique expression the the
first biblical use of it by the Lord in
dealing with
Satan the same expression is used in
Jude might it not be then that the same
Divine being is revealed here in
Zechariah he was manifested under one of
his titles the angel of the Lord in Jude
under another of his titles
Michael close
quote Yeah we can know that this might
be false by more closely paying
attention to the two texts that are
being appealed
to so to make sure you get their
thinking they claim that the phrase the
Lord rebuke thee is significant to
identify Michael as the angel of the
Lord because the text is only found in
or that phrase is only found in two
places Jude n and Zechariah 3:2 in Jude
n they say Michael uses this phrase and
in Zechariah three the angel of the Lord
does both times rebuking Satan thus
Michael and the angel of the Lord must
be the same Divine
being
false notice in Jude
nine Michael doesn't do the rebuking he
leaves the rebuking to the Lord meaning
Michael himself distinguishes himself
from the
Lord the same Jude has already said in
Jude 5 four versus PR
that Jesus is the Lord who led the
Israelites out of slavery in
Egypt then four verses later he tells us
Michael distinguishes himself from that
Lord that did that which is more
evidence that Jesus is not Michael but
nevertheless Michael and Jude doesn't do
the
rebuking whereas in Zechariah 3 the
angel of the Lord does do the
rebuking they apparently didn't read the
text carefully enough because this
actually shows they're not the same
figure and just so we are clear Ellen
White herself commented on this and
claimed that Jesus as Michael didn't do
the rebuking but left it to the Lord so
even she distinguished Michael from the
Lord who was the one doing the
rebuking claim to be shown this in
Vision spiritual gifts volume 1 page 43
quote
I saw that Moses passed through death
but Michael came down and gave him life
before he saw corruption Satan claimed
the body as his but Michael resurrected
Moses and took him to heaven the devil
tried to hold his body and railed out
bitterly against God denounced him as
unjust in taking from him his prey but
Michael did not rebuke the devil
although it was through his temptation
and power that God's servant had
Fallen Christ meekly referred him to his
father saying the Lord rebuke thee close
quote so what was claimed in questions
on Doctrine does not align with this
alleged divinely inspired statement that
they tell us in no way contradicts or
adds to the Bible even though the Bible
doesn't teach that Michael resurrected
Moses and took his body to Heaven they
say this because they'll point to the
Transfiguration to say see Moses was
there so that must have meant he was
resurrected no it
doesn't and in Matthew's accounting of
the
Transfiguration he tells you it was a
vision a
vision
furthermore it was historically known
that Moses and elishah were
representatives of the law and the
prophets what Jesus was revealing
revealing to the disciples in the
Transfiguration
was that the law and the prophets were
in effect until Jesus's
resurrection when the New Covenant era
would be ushered in that is a short
summary of what's going on there but
nowhere does the bible tell us that
Michael resurrected Moses and in
fact there's been debate over this
wording for a long time because in some
instances the B the phrase the body of
Moses has been phraseology that's been
used to refer to the pentat the writing
of
Moses the word of
God and so there's argument that this
text could be referring to that being
what was wrestled
over but the book of Watchers or The
Book of Enoch is more than likely what
Jude was was appealing to which is not
sacred scripture but if you go and read
that accounting you'll see how the
author notes that Michael didn't bring a
charge against Satan because he knew
that he was a formidable foe
powerful and Michael knew his place so
instead of rebuking Satan he trusted in
God to take care of him which makes
sense regarding Jude distinguishing
Michael from the one Lord Jesus Christ
the almighty
God but they are stuck having to affirm
that they are the same figure because
Ellen White said so in Patriarchs and
Prophets which they believe is is
divinely inspired writings divine
revelation from God himself
she stated that Jesus was revealed to
the prophets and Israel as the angel of
the Lord the captain of the Lord's hosts
and Michael the
Archangel that all three are just Jesus
but not just names remember that the
name is also tied to him becoming an
angel and taking their nature upon
himself which is damnable heresy a false
Christ the point being Michael's not the
angel of the Lord the angel of the Lord
in the Old Testament is not a creature
or an Angelic being having an Angelic
nature it is indeed a title for the
pre-incarnate Christ who was present all
throughout the Old Testament and even
manifested himself in physical form
before actually incarnating as a man the
angel of the Lord forgives sins he's
worshiped these are things the Old
Testament says only God the almighty is
worthy of and can do Michael is an
Angelic created being two different
figures and the angel of the Lord in the
Old Testament was not Jesus incarnated
with an Angelic nature being tested
while also trying to save apostate
Angels but they rejected
him and again Ellen White was still
alive at the time of writing this
where's her rebuke on this adous friend
I'd love to see
it now we get to the January 11 1905
issue of signs of the
times less than one year later they have
an article titled consider him an angel
talking about
Jesus in this one we get a few more
details that fill out the claim of Jesus
as Michael more fully this particular
article has several different subheads
such as consider him consider him as a
mouthpiece of God consider him as an
angel
Etc here's what they say imploring you
to consider Jesus as an angel
quote consider him as an angel a mess
Meer a servant of God Among the
Angels Messengers servants himself the
chiefest of Angel because the uh because
the greatest
servant then known as Michael who is
like God the Archangel by service
preeminent
therefore was he the special angel of
Jehovah who spoke with Abraham who
wrestled with Jacob who led Israel
through the Red Sea and the Wilderness
who spake the law from Heaven who gave
unto Moses the Lively oracles speaking
as the voice of God from deity crowned
cyani he came as the angel of God's
presence of whom the Lord assures us my
name is in
him as the messenger of Jehovah he
demonstrated the power of God over sin
in the Angelic sphere fought the great
spiritual battles with Satan the
adversary brought Moses from the dead
and bear witness of God's salvation to
the Fallen Angel host close
quote so again as an angel that took on
an Angelic nature Jesus served as a
messenger as well and in doing so he
fought great spiritual battles with
Satan such as bringing Moses back from
the dead and this was a testimony to the
angels of God's witness of
Salvation and they want you to consider
this yeah I'm I'm good thanks I don't
want to consider an
idol Jesus that incarnated as an angel
and tried saving Angels but none of them
accepted so then he sunk even lower down
to humans where he eternally sacrificed
Divine attributes such as omnipresence
so now he's omnipresent through another
person the holy spirit because he'll
forever be humiliated by eternally
having a human
body yet Jesus is human flesh is
glorified his humiliation is done it was
temporary that's just simply referring
to him coming
down he won't be eternally humiliated by
having a body nor did he lose anything
in the Incarnation he temporarily veiled
his glory stepping down from his lofty
Abode accomplished the work of the new
creation redeeming what man broke and
then he return to his rightful status as
the God man to Forever Rule and reign as
such Over All creation forever returning
to that glorious state that he shared
eternally with the father and the
spirit but this paragraph also shows you
how they will appeal to Revelation 12
and say that there was war in heaven and
try and make that refer to something
that took place before the Earth was
even
created I mean just reading the the
chapter clearly shows this makes no
sense it's like it's obviously talking
about after Earth's creation because it
happens around the of the woman being
caught up to heaven that's Jesus at the
Ascension yet some will try and use that
to support the aous Jesus having a
battle with Satan when he was an
angel seven months later in the same
year again signs of the times August 16
1905 they published a series of articles
that were titled suggestive propositions
on the priesthood of Christ the great
controversy between good and evil in
number two of that series
they again talk about Jesus as Michael
the
Archangel remember questions on Doctrine
said they weren't even really talking
about this subject in their written
literature yeah we once again see them
proposing some more ideas around this
subject
quote as Michael the Archangel Christ
fought the great spiritual warfare with
Satan for 4,000
Years yet during all this time he
brought no railing accusation against
the adversary but met with him Jehovah
rebuke thee Oh Satan Zechariah 3:2 and
Jude 9 the Son of God had not yet met
the fullest test he had not gone down to
the lowest depths Ephesians
4:9 as Michael the Archangel he overcame
and Lucifer and his host failed neither
was their place found anymore in heaven
Revelation
128 close
quote Yeah except we already saw how
they're conflating Jude n with Zechariah
3 but once again see them say Jesus
becoming an angel and taking on their
nature taking on an Angelic nature as
Michael the Archangel and this was part
of a test where he overcame Satan as an
angel
himself and this spiritual warfare
lasted 4,000 years
supposedly and like I mentioned earlier
Revelation 128 is appealed to to try and
say this is biblical not even
close but this article also proposes
that by becoming an
angel Jesus had not yet met the fullest
test which was sinking even lower and
becoming a man with a human
nature this further affirms that the
previous article was not a one-off
they're saying the same thing in the
same year in the same publication and
Ellen White is still alive and doesn't
correct
it if someone can show us that happening
that would be great but good
luck one month later the same year
September 27 1905 in signs of the times
yet again they give more suggestions on
the meisan priesthood just like in the
previous
month within that they say some stuff
about Michael they write
quote When sin entered the universe of
God the preeminent Son of God emptied
himself of all his glory took upon
himself the form of a servant and
descended even to nothingness that he
might vindicate the character of God to
be love and to save all who would be
saved in the early part of his
humiliation he was Michael the Archangel
the servant of God during this time he
fought the great spiritual warfare with
Satan yet bringing no railing accusation
against him even meeting his attacks
with the Lord rebuke thee Oh Satan close
quote so remember the article earlier
that talked about God's character of
love being displayed to the
angels that included Jesus becoming an
angel himself sharing their nature and
Waring with Satan and he passed the test
to demonstrate that God is who he says
he is Satan's a liar Etc this is what
will ultimately vindicate God's
character of Love
supposedly over and over and over again
they're saying the same things it's not
cryptic it's not unclear
they are very openly claiming that Jesus
Took upon himself an angel nature to
engage in Angelic Ministry to try and
fight for the Salvation of angels they
all rejected him
though then he moved to the next step
sinking down even lower to the Earth to
take on a permanent human nature after
4,000 years of Waring with Satan as an
angel yeah definitely not the Jesus of
the Bible
folks you would never get this from
reading the Bible
only when you get this world view from
Ellen White's books and then bring that
story line to the Bible to try and fit
this stuff in between the gaps and do
the whole well it doesn't contradict the
Bible even if it's not there yeah in all
sorts of groups out there do that and it
leads to
deception there's a lot of Truth here
mixed in with error which is what makes
it deceptive yes the angel of the Lord
is the almighty God no he's not Michael
yes Jesus will forever be the God man
and retain his physical glorified human
body no he didn't eternally sacrifice
anything he had prior to incarnating as
a
man yes Jesus sought to seek and save
lost Sinners human Sinners Not
Angels is a very crafty
deception as a brief aside I hope you're
seeing how this is not the same idea as
the Jehovah's
Witnesses what they say in question
questions on Doctrine was carefully
crafted to still allow for all this
stuff that we're that we're reading to
be
affirmed without them having to get into
all that because they don't get into any
of this in the in the question a of that
book they focused strictly on their
belief not being the same as the
Jehovah's Witnesses but they don't get
into any of these
details because they know that had
Walter Martin read such a thing his cult
radar would have gone
off this was before the
internet so I don't know how easily he
could have accessed this
info but those days are long gone and
I'm going to sound the alarm on this as
loud as I possibly can and seek to
inform as many Christians as possible
this is absolutely cultic it falls
outside the bounds of Christian
Orthodoxy regarding christology is not
Christian teaching it's not compatible
with the god who has revealed himself in
the Incarnation and the scriptures
that's what I mean by
cultic so David asri take note text me
call me let's talk about this you have
my
number none of this stuff is compatible
with what some of the Protestant
reformers believed either not a single
one of them believed that Jesus Took on
an angel nature to try and save the
Angels but they all rejected
him it's not at all compatible with
orthodox trinitarianism and every single
Protestant reformer was an orthodox
trinitarian so don't give me this
nonsense that eminent Christian Scholars
agree with our view no they
don't so the Adventist Church needs to
stop trying to drag them into this mess
to try and add legitimacy to this
concept the great controversy theme
makes every single Adventist teaching
entirely unique because that extra
biblical story line informs how they
read teach interpret the
Bible already we've seen that every
point they mention from questions on
Doctrine is
false the Five Points that I showed at
the
beginning Jesus is not Michael the
Archangel they did write about this a
lot in their printed Publications
eminent Christian scholarship did not
and does not agree with this the name
Michael isn't just a name in their
system but they're tying it to Jesus
actually be becoming an Angel With An
Angel nature to do Angelic Ministry to
try and save the apostate
angels and what they are claiming when
looked at comprehensively absolutely
disparages the person and work of
Christ it attributes things to the true
Christ that he didn't do it entirely
Alters his person and
work doesn't even get into the fact that
he entirely failed with every single
Angel he didn't get a single one of them
not a single Angel was saved how
pathetic what a weak pathetic
Idol it's like Elijah with the prophets
of Baal he says your God sitting on the
toilet is that why you can't call fire
down
pathetic
furthermore all of this contradicts
God's self-revelation in his holy
word like I showed earlier and there's
more which is akin to calling God a liar
when he's told us one thing and they're
telling us something
else just think about that folks what an
abject failure not a single Angel was
saved he apparently tried for 4,000
years he was pleading please please he's
this weak beggar gosh their God is just
pathetic Tried by for 4,000 years to
save the Angels couldn't convince a
single one to accept his offer because
you know Free Will in their their model
is basically
God that's the real God in their system
the AVST Angel Jesus couldn't convince a
single Angel to use their free will to
choose him
Mercy but none of that disparages the
work of Christ in their minds it
apparently magnifies God's love for the
angels and humans and it vindicates his
character moving six months ahead to the
March 7 1906 issue of signs of the times
in an article titled the crisis of the
world they again bring up Michael and
reiterate this same stuff in this
article they claim that the Supreme
crisis of the world did not occur at the
cross of
Calvary not when the Roman soldiers
mocked Christ not when he was ridiculed
and blasphemed by the Jewish priests not
even when God the father's face was
hidden from the Son and the awful dark
Ness of sin rung from Christ's lips
while on the cross but the Supreme
crisis of the universe they write took
place in the Garden of Gethsemane after
explaining this they write
quote there had been other
crises when he gave himself a lamb slain
from the foundation of the world a
crisis was passed when he took upon
himself the form of a servant and became
an angel among the Angels a crisis was
passed when he was made in the likeness
of man a crisis was passed when he met
the mighty Temptations of the adversary
at the beginning of his ministry and
conquered by faith in the word of God a
crisis was passed and there doubtless
were other times but the Supreme crisis
was met in the Garden of Gethsemane when
alone with God Jesus Christ yielded
himself again with renewed consecration
facing all the suffering to become the
Supreme and everlasting sacrifice for
Humanity the crucifixion and the
resurrection were but the demonstration
in life of the submission of
Gethsemane close quote so again they're
reiterating the previous article we saw
where they talked about the various
tests that Jesus allegedly underwent and
that one of those was when he became an
angel among the Angels which we saw what
all that supposedly
entailed once again I remind you Ellen
White was still alive at this time and I
know it sounds redundant but the point
is is this isn't one-offs they're saying
this over over and over and over and
over
again fast forward to May the following
year May 15 1907 again sign signs of The
Times They once again reiterate what
we've already seen proving that none of
this is a one-off from an article titled
the manner of Christ coming they write
quote the work of Jesus Christ in the
great scheme of Salvation is made up of
different steps and acts he stepped down
from the Throne of deity and gave
himself for the Salvation of of his
creatures he became an angel messenger
of God Among the angels He Stoops lower
and is incarnated a man among men he met
the climax of his eternal Sacrifice by
his death upon the cross he arose again
he ascended on high he ministers as
priest before God he comes again in
glory Transcendent
Supernatural close
quote yeah and now we as we saw
all this you know becoming an angel
messenger we already saw what all that
entails taking on an angel nature to try
and save Angels Waring with Satan as an
angel for 4,000 years pleading with the
angels to choose to be saved by him but
every last one of them refused an abject
failure then in the same month same
publication the following week May 22nd
they published a question question and
answer where they answer things that
Adventists were inquiring about one of
which is regarding the Archangel so the
questioner asked quote is not the
Archangel Michael the executive of the
Holy Spirit the one that overshadowed
the Virgin Mary Etc to which the answer
is
given if you will read the account in
the first chapter of Luke it was not the
Angel Michael but the angel Gabriel
Michael means who is like God Archangel
means chief of all the Angels such was
the son of God before he became a
man he who is like God became the
Archangel and then stepped lower down
and became the Lord Jesus among men Jude
9 1 Thessalonians 4:16 and Daniel 121
show very clearly that Michael is Christ
Gabriel is doubt is doubtless his Angel
Revelation 1 1-3 the one who instructed
the prophets but as to saying that any
one Angel is executive of the spirit of
God that is limiting it to the capacity
of that angel all God's angels are
ministers and All God's Children upon
whom and in whom is placed his Spirit
are also ministers or servants just the
same as every member of the whole body
of man is the executive of the mind of
man close
quote so this further solidifies that by
Angel they don't just mean a role
they once again affirmed that before
incarnating as a man Jesus became an
angel becoming Michael the Archangel
followed by sinking even lower by taking
on the nature of a
man is all of this out of context
advinus prove me wrong go show me that
every single one of these quotes is out
of context that I'm
misrepresenting make my day
we then have a break at least as far as
I could find and we move up to February
1st
1910 this time in the
publication the Oriental
Watchmen this was an official SDA
publication in
India the first and only SDA Publishing
House in India according to the SDA
encyclopedia again we have a question
and answer section in this particular
publication the entire section was on
angs within that we find this
quote question who's the chief of the
Angels answer Michael the Archangel Jude
n note Michael the Archangel is none
other than Christ he's often spoken of
by men as entirely distinct from our
Lord sometimes the term is used in the
plural the Bible however knows but one
Archangel the term Arc means Chief when
placed before a noun beginning with a
vowel or vowel sound the CH takes the
hard form when placed before a consonant
the ordinary sound as in
Archbishop the Archangel is therefore
the commander among the Angels Michael
means who is like God therefore through
all the past dispensations Christ is
called the angel of
Jehovah close quote so once again they
conf Michael the Archangel with the
angel of the Lord the reason they argue
that Michael is the only Archangel is
because they need that to be the case
for Jesus to be
Michael think about it if there are
multiple archangels then that refutes
this notion hence we see what is put
forth here as well as countless other
SDA sources like the SDA encyclopedia
and the SDA Bible
dictionary
however Ellen who is supposed to guide
them into all truth and protect them
from doctrinal error contradicts this
over and over and over again because she
claimed that Satan was an archangel
too notice signs of the time September
14 1882 she writes
quote Rebellion originated with Satan
notwithstanding the exalted position
which he occupied among the Heavenly
Host he became dissatisfied because he
was not accounted Supreme
honor hence he questioned God's purposes
and imputed his Justice he bent all his
powers to Allure the angels from their
allegiance the fact that he was an
archangel glorious and Powerful enabled
him to exert a mighty influence his
complaints against God's government aka
the law at first met with no favor yet
being urged again and again they were
finally accepted by those who had before
been loyal and happy subjects of the
king of Heaven
close
quote so she apparently contradicts the
Bible
then because the Oriental Watchmen told
us the Bible only knows of but one
Archangel yet Ellen White claims Satan
was an archangel which is why he was
able to deceive a third of the angels
and convince them to rebel against
God and this very clearly further
affirms and supports the
thesis that there was a time where Jesus
and Satan were both seen as archangels
and one got a promotion the other didn't
so he became jealous of Jesus's
promotion leading to this great
controversy over God and His law but
again in sermons and talks volume one
page 241 she said quote cherubims and
seraphim Angels and Archangels plural
are watching the battle that's going on
in this life between whom the Prince of
Life and the power of Darkness close
quote
Arch Angels
plural in the great controversy between
Jesus and Satan angels and Arch angels
are watching the battle raging on
supposedly again in the lngg white 1888
material she writes quote Angels and
Archangels are looking upon God's chosen
ones with the most Earnest interest to
see what influence the truth is having
upon mind and character to see how much
they appreciate the one who was CR
crucified for them that they might have
eternal life close
quote Angels and Archangels
plural this is allegedly divinely
inspired information folks supposed to
help shed light onto the Bible and help
us really understand what the Bible s is
teaching and saying correcting of
inaccurate interpretations of the
Bible like the inaccurate interpretation
that there's only one Archangel and it's
Michael again in Heavenly places we see
her say the same thing plural
archangels that all of Heaven is
worshiping Jesus the lamb which includes
Angels archangels plural seraphim and
cherubim folks there is a reason that I
call this system schizophrenic theology
Whiplash theology just constant
confusion contradictions Etc they can
never keep the story straight it's
always changing always evolving the gold
posts are always shifting and it's just
the present truth magic wand is pulled
out and bonk it's all fixed present
truth ah how convenient
right but this is supposed to be the
movement that has the theological God
Particle a special Insight that only
they have that God gave them to help
them be United unlike all of us
doctrinally confused Babylon Protestants
and Catholics and Orthodox and copics
and yeah we're apostates and rejected by
God you know the True Body of
Christ yeah we're not the one making
insane christological blunders like
this our Creeds summarize biblical
christology to a te and don't result in
this sort of Whiplash and actual
confusion but notice this there's
another question in that same issue of
the Orient to
Watchmen so the question is asked after
our Lord's exaltation who took his place
as the chief of the
Angels
huh a
man after our Lord's exaltation who took
his place as the chief of the
Angels the answer is then given Gabriel
whose name means man of God sometimes
called man coming to men in the form of
men see Daniel 816 and Luke 1:19 and
26 close
quote so hold up hold up hold up hold up
read this carefully
folks after Jesus was exalted who took
his place as chief of the Angels
well when was Jesus an angel to then be
exalted so that Gabriel could take his
place this would mean that Jesus was an
angel was exalted to be made equal with
God the Father leaving a vacancy
resulting in God then exalting Gabriel
to fill Jesus's vacant spot
yeah what a total mess of
blasphemy none of these proof texts
support
this literally not a single one of them
says anything about Gabriel being
exalted it is amazing the the proof
texting they will do and the inference
that they will try and draw out of that
to try and make all of this appear
biblical now the biblical witness on
this all of this stuff about the the
Archangel being only one Archangel Etc
alen white
aside this publication claimed Archangel
according to the Bible there's only
one yeah Archangel isn't just a title
folks it's a type of an Angelic
being a type of created Angelic
being and Ellen White was correct to
point out that there are multiple
archangels because that's what the
biblical witness
portrays forar starters we looked at
Hebrews 2 earlier well chapter 1 through
two are dealing with how Jesus is
entirely distinct and separate from the
angels in every way he's not comparable
to them in any
regard notice Hebrews 1 1 through
five long ago at many times and in many
ways God spoke to our fathers by the
prophets but in these last days he spoke
unto us by his son whom he appointed the
heir of all things through whom also he
created the world he's the radiance of
the glory of God and the exact imprint
of his nature and he upholds the
universe by the word of his power after
making purification for sins he sat down
at the right hand of the Majesty on High
having become as much Superior to angels
as the name he has inherited is more
excellent than theirs for to which of
the Angels did God ever say you are my
son today I've begotten you or again I
will be uh him a father and he shall be
to me a
son that's Hebrews
1 the SDA sources have told us multiple
times that the first step in the son of
God's humiliation was to First Take on
the nature of an Angel among the rest of
the
angels and that he was God among them
which is what a source is going to tell
us here in a little bit yet Hebrews 1
explicit L states that God never called
an angel his son so how could the Son of
God have taken on the nature of an Angel
as the Son of God before sinking even
lower to take on human
nature If This Were true it would mean
that when the AVST Jesus Took on an
Angelic nature to do Angelic Ministry to
the angels He ceased being the Son of
God because the holy spirit in Hebrews
just told us that God the father was
never called an
angel or God the father is never called
an angel his son
sorry not just this but it also tells us
that Jesus is superior to the angels
like we saw earlier in Chapter 2 it
explicitly states that Jesus didn't seek
to save the Angels but The Offspring of
Abraham human beings so that's one but
then we get the infamous Daniel 1013
passage which is on
screen that they've tried to twist and
contort to mean anything other than what
it plainly says so Daniel in vision sees
one who resembles the figure of a man
who speaks to him and in the flow of
what that figure tells him we read
quote then he said to me fear not Daniel
for from the first day that you set your
heart to understand and humbled yourself
before your God your words have been
heard and I've come because of your
words the prince of the kingdom of
Persia withstood me 21 days but Michael
one of the chief princes came to help me
for I was left there with the kings of
pers
and came to make you understand what is
to happen to your people in the latter
days for the vision is for days yet to
come thus the reading of God's holy
word so this figure tells
Daniel that Michael is but one of the
archangels or chief princes which
indicates there are others like
him so Archangel is a type of angelic
creature it's not simply a title for the
sole head or leader of the angel
there are multiple
archangels and even in Jewish angelology
they discuss they discuss this sub uh
subject you know some avist love to try
and appeal to Jewish understanding to
support their views like that Satan is
oaz Zeal therefore Satan must be a
picture of the scapegoat in Leviticus
16 yeah they'll appeal to Jewish
apocryphal sources on this but not
regarding Jewish angelology which
understands Angels uh archangels as a
type of angelic created
beings now we get to the year 1911 and
this is where they start to get a lot
more specific again first in 1911
questions and answers volume one of the
signs of the times which was a a
essentially a book that they published
where it was compiling all these
different q&as from the the publication
of signs of the times from number 14
which is titled made like unto his
Brethren Hebrews
2:14-17 how ironic considering like we
saw earlier this picape refutes this
entire notion that he tried to save
Angels but they refused so then he sunk
lower beginning his next step in his
humiliation to try and save mankind they
write
quote from the foundation of the world
Christ gave himself emptied himself that
he might break the power of sin unifying
God's broken creation and save men
Revelation 13 1 Peter Philippians 2
again when he did this he gave up all
counted not the being of an equality
with God a thing to be grasped he
emptied himself laying aside his deity
taking the form of a
servant he first in the carrying out of
his sacrifice became an angel among the
Angels Chief Angel Archangel only
because he was the most devoted
messenger of God in his position he is
called Michael meaning who is like God
close quote so again I know this is
repetitive but the point is they're
publishing and saying this stuff over
and over and over again to claim that
they weren't really talking about this
in their printed work when they knew
Walter Martin was examining their
Doctrine for signs of being cultic was
Classic slipperiness on their part
don't give me that this was regularly
popping up in their Publications over
the Spain of
decades we're not even we're only
halfway through
almost they once again claim that the
humiliation of Christ entailed more than
just taking on human
nature the first step involved becoming
an angel among the Angels where he was
the chiefest of such Michael the
Archangel because he was the most
devoted angel Messenger to
God and he was given the name Michael
upon doing this because he was like
God yeah being Yahweh the almighty isn't
merely being like God it's being God by
very
definition now we get to a source that
I've shown before many times this is the
one that sent me down this whole rabbit
hole
signs of the times June 6
1911 this is from an article titled the
Son of God notes and comment in this
section they're providing clarification
regarding what they teach about Satan's
accusations in this pre-earth
controversy that started over Jesus's
exaltation to be made equal with God the
father and in this section they write
quote for that time that or or yeah for
that time that moment that now the the
ages had
waited from the time that he who
afterward became Jesus of Nazareth left
his position in the godhead as the
creator of Heaven and
Earth and for the sake of his Fallen
creatures
plural risked all to save them the
universe had been in
suspense in the beginning he was one
with the father in Supernatural Glory
John 17 the very image of his is talking
about the father substance Hebrews 1:3
but his position of equality his claim
to Eternal sunship had been disputed by
that being who stood next to him the one
created being above all others who in
himself sealed up the sum of bestowed
wisdom and Beauty Ezekiel 28 Lucifer the
son of the morning Isaiah
14 he not only disputed the position of
the word of God but he led others to do
the same
a third part of Heaven's spirits of
light revolted the universe was divided
broken diseased by the entrance of sin
God's power might have been Vindicated
by utterly crushing the rebellion of
Lucifer in the beginning but such a
course would have swn doubt in the minds
of beings who were on probation yet
still loyal it was God's character that
was called in question his Justice his
love if God's creatures could be led to
believe that God is not love that he's
unjust partial implacable unmerciful
that would not serve him or they would
not serve him would fall as easy prey to
Satan's
deceptions close
quote so this is just like the the the
quote that we read back in the 1800s
basically just repurposing that changing
some words around so when the Son of God
became Jesus of Nazareth he allegedly
left his position in the godhead as the
creator of Heaven and Earth and for the
sake of Fallen creatures he risked it
all to try and save them which left the
universe in
suspense notice it said for the sake of
his Fallen creatures plural not just
humans but
angels and like I mentioned earlier by
this point they'd pivoted off of their
original Aryan and semian Roots despite
Ellen White claiming to receive Visions
at that time which confirmed the semi
semian teachings as being correct
so by this point they've tried to spin
it that Lucifer became jealous of
something that had always been the case
like we saw
earlier Jesus was also equal with God
the father and Satan made false charges
against this as the one who was next to
Jesus the son in
Authority like we saw earlier they
reiterate the same thing from a few
decades prior that instead of God just
crushing Satan upon his Rebellion God
allowed it to persist because if he
would have done that by just crushing
him out it would have communicated to
the angels that Satan was right that
God's a tyrant Etc and it would have
called into question God's character
which is the whole thing in question
here again proving that this is this was
a consistent teaching not some oneoff
here they continue by saying
quote but God is merciful kind loving
just therefore God bore with Lucifer in
his rebellious host
therefore he gave them opportunity to
repent and
return therefore he pleaded with them as
only deity could plead to restore them
to righteousness and
life how do we know this because it is
thus that God pleads now and he's
eternally the same without variableness
or shadow of turning the Eternal Word
gave himself he did not aspire to be
equal with God did not meditate a usurp
of the Throne of the universe
Philippians 2 but he emptied himself
gave himself then and there for Sinners
he took the form of a servant becoming
an angel among the angels that he might
redeem Angels but they would
not and when they rejected the
righteousness and life so freely offered
he descended lower still to those duped
by Satan Fallen man stooping even to
death that he might redeem of the Fallen
all who desire to be redeemed and
vindicate to the universe to all
eternity the character of God that was
the work of the word of God the Eternal
logos when he became Michael the
Archangel when he became Jesus the man
of Nazareth when he was anointed the
Christ when he died our sacrifice on
Calvary yet during all this time the
hosts of evil with all the baleful
deceptive cruel devices of sin were
hurled against him that God's character
might be marred that the great
Vindicator Redeemer might fall close
quote so like I said they essentially
republished here what we saw from a
couple decades
prior Jesus Took upon himself an angel
nature to try and save the Angels this
was the first step in his humiliation
supposedly totally foreign to the Bible
folks the Bible nowhere says that
Jesus's humiliation had multiple
steps but every single angel that
rebelled with Satan rejected this
attempt by the son of God to save them
so then he moved to step two where he
sunk even lower down to our level and
all of this was ultimately to vindicate
the character of God which is on trial
due to accusations made by Satan prior
to the Earth even
existing this is why they have a false
gospel folks they are altering the work
of
Christ The Gospel is the person and work
of Christ who is he what did he
accomplish what did he do he never
became an angel in his humiliation to
try and save Angels but they all
rejected
him Christians do not believe this
because the Bible does not teach
this and it does disparage the Lord
Jesus when you claim that he did things
he didn't
do it's called bearing false
witness especially considering the claim
is also made that he utterly failed to
save even a single angel in the process
like a pathe
weakling this is after 1890 folks after
the publishing of Desire of Ages which
is when SDA scholarship tells us they
finally had their christology ironed out
and they embraced Christian Orthodoxy in
this area insisting they believe the
same thing Christians do Ellen White is
still alive during this time and
provides no rebuke or
correction in fact fact she was
published in this same issue of signs of
the times where she wrote an article
titled Plan of Salvation number
four they're talking about this Michael
stuff in the same series of articles
that she's contributing
to are we to think that she wasn't aware
of any of
these that she's being published
alongside them and wasn't on
board first notice what they write in
their fundamental beliefs book regarding
doctrinal Unity quote Under The Heading
Unity of Faith they write diversity of
spiritual gifts does not mean A
diversity of beliefs
however in the last days God's church
will be composed of people who share a
common platform of the Everlasting
gospel their lives characterized by the
observance of The Commandments of God
and the faith of Jesus Revelation
2412 together they Proclaim to the world
God's invitation to Salvation close
close
quote so they're supposed to be
doctrinally United unlike the rest of us
and this is supposed to set them apart
from the rest of us Babylonian confused
Protestants and Roman Catholics and
Orthodox their doctrinal Unity is
supposed to be part of what identifies
them as God's last day
people well as we have seen they're
claiming this belief in Jesus coming as
M you know becoming Michael and assuming
the nature of an Angel to try and seek
and save the Angels was step one in
Jesus's work of
humiliation it was a necessary step for
him to be tested as an angel before all
of the angels to vindicate God and His
law demonstrating that Satan is a
liar which is absolutely Central to the
entire great controversy storyline of
theology so are they all United on this
issue David asri told us in that intro
clip this doesn't even make the top 15
top 20 importance list of the doctrines
for
him I'd venture to bet 95% of Seventh
Day Adventist Ley aren't even aware of
these sources and claims or the larger
role that this plays within their belief
system furthermore they also write that
part of the role of a valid biblical
prophit is to protect the flock from
doctrinal
error to protect them from being tossed
to and fro by every wind of
Doctrine
quote prophets help to bring about the
unity of
Faith protect the church against false
doctrines so Believers would no longer
be infants tossed back and forth by the
waves and blown here and there by every
wind of teaching and by every cunning
and craftiness of people in their
deceitful scheming close
quote Yeah well numerous primary sources
tell us that Michael is the only
Archangel Ellen White repeatedly said
there were
multiple the primary sources are telling
us that Jesus became an Angel With An
Angel nature to do Angelic Ministry to
try and save the Angels which
contradicts scripture and yet Ellen
White doesn't even correct it and is
found being published alongside these
same
articles so how is that protecting from
doctrinal
error again when this isn't something
some side
issue I know many Adventists think
that's the
case many individual Adventists think
case but as we are
seeing you have to separate individual
Ley from their own and their own private
understandings from the organizational
claims and
statements I'm sorry most Adventists are
just not learning on their own
theological system
okay doesn't make them bad people it's
just the facts I'm
sorry and I think most honest Adventists
would agree with this the average
Seventh Day Adventist is not getting
into this level of research and
study but this area is a Telltale sign
Surefire sign that Ellen White was not a
protector of error she was actually the
cause of a lot of it and she's the
primary reason they're in such a bind
today
moving ahead three weeks to the June 27
1911 issue of signs of the times again
from the question Corner section where
they're answering questions from the
leoty this questioner asked about the
pre-existence of Christ get this
folks so remember by this point they've
moved past the aryanism of the early
days and their postd Desire of Ages
being published which was supposed to be
when they arrived at
trinitarianism Ellen White is still
alive here she died four years later we
read
quote this Angel Jehovah bore a name
among the Angels namely Michael the
meaning of which is who is like God he's
represented as a person one who goes and
comes greater and mightier than Gabriel
Daniel 10:13 in fact he's called Michael
the Archangel the chief of all the
Angels Jude n it is his voice that
raises the Dead 1 Thessalonians 4:16 but
our Lord himself shows that it is his
voice which will raised the dead John
528 and 29 therefore the personal
Michael of the Old Testament is
identified with the Christ of the new
close
quote so are you starting to see a
pattern of assertions and appeals
here that they just recycle the same
stuff over and over and over and over
again the same proof text the same
assertions
Etc none of these proof texts prove that
the angel of the Lord in the Old
Testament is
Michael the only proof text we haven't
dealt with tonight is 1 Thessalonians
4:16 though we've done so
elsewhere what's funny about that text
though is in relation to their claim
that it proves Jesus is Michael that
text says the Lord himself will descend
from heaven with a cry of command with
the voice of an
archangel and with the sound of the
trumpet of God and the dead in Christ
will rise
first it says an archangel
not the
Archangel which they made a big deal
about as we saw earlier but notice their
logic they read first Thessalonians to
be saying the voice of an archangel is
referring to Jesus's voice they then
appeal to John five where Jesus says his
voice will be what raises the dead
therefore Jesus is the Archangel in
first
Thessalonians got it
but it does not say that Jesus is the
Archangel but that there's a loud
announcement made upon the king's
return the phrase suggests that Jesus
comes with the commanding authority of
Heaven what you'll find if you study
this event in depth the second coming
which they're supposed to be Masters
on the imagery we see used is the same
as that of ancient cultures where a king
would enter a city and a representative
of the king would be sent ahead of the
procession to announce the king's
arrival before he and the Entourage got
there you even see this in pop culture
like the Monty Python
movies and it's in Shrek
too that's what's going on
here angels will prede the Son of God
and make an
announcement they're going to announce
before he arrives yo the king is
coming and he's going to strut through
like a
boss and then he's going to enter in
with the Saints and the martyrs Etc and
the dead are going to be raised and it's
going to be
awesome the text does not say that the
Archangel is the one that raises people
from the dead either that's the other
thing that they they
conflate that this text says the voice
of the Archangel is what raises the dead
and only God can do that so therefore
Jesus has to be the Archangel in this
text no friend that's not what it says
that's not what it
says your worldview is being read into
the text it simply says the Lord Jesus
Will descend angels will announce this
and Christ will raise the dead but they
continue in the same article remember
it's focusing upon the pre-existence of
the Son of God to his Incarnation as a
man quote
as a member of the great godhead our
blessed Lord stepped down to live a
servant of God an angel among the Angels
A man among men filled all vacancies
with his fullness of life and character
and triumphed over uh or for every
sinful soul but all the Mysteries we may
not cannot understand anymore than we
can understand the process of digestion
or creation close
quote so notice once again they parallel
what Jesus did as a man to what he did
as an
angel as a man what did he
do he allegedly set his divine nature
aside and took on a human nature same
thing happened when he took on an angel
nature
supposedly completely consistent with
what they've been claiming in their
other sources for nearly 30 years at
this
point but also notice that they say he
filled all vacancies with his fullness
of life in character and triumphed over
every sinful Soul or for every sinful
Soul
sorry so just like they were previously
publishing Jesus becoming an angel was a
test that included Waring with Satan for
the Salvation of
angels and Jesus on the plane of Angels
triumphed in vindicating God's law
before the Fallen Angels demonstrating
to them that Satan is a liar which is
what he also then went on or or which is
what he he then also went and did as a
man in the second step of his
humiliation they are saying this over
and over and over again folks it's not
one thing here or
there and again Ellen White was
published in the same issue her article
was titled the way of
Christ then we get to October 24 1911
same publication
again they published an article titled
the revelation of Jesus Christ Christ a
review and in that article they speak
about how the Book of Revelation reveals
various things about Jesus in part they
write
quote it is a revelation of Jesus Christ
the son of God it shows to us his
wonderful character his self-denial his
sacrifice it reveals to us his work
which is not only the Vindication of
God's character of love but which means
also the Everlasting Triumph of his
people and the utter blotting out of sin
he's the great hero of this great drama
of the ages we see him with the father
before the world was the creator of the
heavens and the Earth we see him when
the Great problem of sin entered the
universe stepping down from that high
State and becoming one with the
creatures that he himself had brought
into
existence I'm going to read that again
we see him when great problems of sin
entered the universe stepping down from
that highest state and becoming one with
the creatures that he himself had
brought into existence we find him as
Michael the Archangel leading the angels
of good against the forces of evil in
the spiritual
Realms we find him stepping down lower
still and becoming one with the children
of men the Son of God yet the son of man
and even here he steps lower still and
becomes obedient to death giving his
very life in order that he might redeem
men the Lamb of God slain in purpose
from the foundation of the world but
executed in fact on Calvary close
quote so
notice they said that Revelation teaches
that When sin entered the universe Jesus
stepped down from his highest state and
became one with the creatures that he
himself brought into existence including
both humans and
Angels the two classes of Fallen
creatures and as Michael the Archangel
he was head of the good angels in a
battle against Satan and evil
angels after this he stepped down
stopped being an angel and became a
man this is all out of context right
none of these sources are teaching that
Jesus was at one point an Angel With An
Angel
nature not just a messenger but actually
possessed an Angelic nature like the
created angels do
they continue
quote then follows the great Sevenfold
spiritual
controversy
Sevenfold a controversy in the spiritual
Realms between Satan and Michael Satan
represented in the form of a dragon
Michael the Archangel who becomes the
son of the woman the woman the church
the controversy for the destruction of
the church chapter 12 this is where it
gets really bizarre folks Satan's agents
are represented by the heads Babylonian
son in nature worship Persian son in
fire worship The Grecian Pantheon in art
worship the iron monarchy of Rome a
defiled State man and God Steed during
the Dark Ages back to tradition
following that and the full ripeness of
apostasy and the persecuted Church the
dragon still inspiring it all close
quote so
Revelation 12 is supposedly the biblical
support that Jesus became Michael the
Archangel taking on the nature of
created angels to war with Satan what a
mess but notice that they said that
Michael became the son of the woman the
woman being the church where in the
world does revelation 12 say
this it it says Michael and his angels w
with the
dragon nothing about Michael the
Archangel becoming the son of the church
oh right because well through inference
it says that the the the son of the
woman the seed of the woman and because
that's referring to Michael because
that's Jesus and the woman represents
the church oh oh it's one of
those and ah yes you guessed it Ellen
White was also published in the same
issue of signs as well
an article titled Christ adjusts the
claims between Earth and
Heaven was she entirely ignorant that
this is being published alongside her
why no correcting for saying that Jesus
became an angel like the Angelic
creatures not just a title for the head
of the Angels not just a name that's
given to
Jesus then we get to April 2nd 1912 six
months later
they published an article titled signs
in or studies in Daniel a vision of
Empires number seven which was part of a
larger series of articles that they
published over time in this one they
again bring up Michael the Archangel
this is under the subheading of that
article titled the need of teaching
symbols where they talk about how Israel
needed taught things through symbols and
signs because they disregarded God's law
and needed to be taught like children
are taught they write quote bit of a
long one here they talking about Israel
themselves needed object lessons and
symbols and so a sanctuary was built the
holy shakina of God's presence was there
in order to teach the nation which seem
so slow to grasp his his great truth
they could not grasp as did Moses that
God was among them constantly that the
great God who made Heaven and Earth was
always near them and ready to help them
that the word which he spoke was not in
heaven AAR off that someone should climb
up to bring it down
that it was not in the deep that someone
should go down into the deep and bring
it up but it was nigh to them in their
mouth and in their heart Deuteronomy 30
so God wanted to dwell with his people
and each individual soul but they would
not therefore he said let them make me a
sanctuary that I may dwell among them
Exodus
258 in this God would manifest his
presence and His glory and there would
be connected with that which would
continually teach the children of Israel
of
God he sent his angels to minister to
them nay More Than This the very Angel
of the Covenant the Archangel Michael he
who afterward became Jesus of Nazareth
the angel in whom was God's name became
companion with them behold I sent an
angel before thee to keep thee in the
way and to bring thee in the place which
I have prepared beware of him and obey
his voice provoke him not for he will
not pardon your transgressions for my
name is in him but if Thou shalt indeed
obey his voice and do all that I speak
then I will be an enemy unto thine
enemies and an adversary unto thine
adversaries for mine Angel shall go
before thee close quote so again they
confused the angel of the Lord with
Michael the Archangel but remember how
question in questions on Doctrine asked
whether or not Michael the Archangel was
Jesus prior to his
Incarnation this is about the 100 source
that we've seen where they're plainly
saying this yet they didn't bother to
get into this in questions on Doctrine
they ignored that part of the question
and focused on making sure it was clear
that they don't agree with the Jehovah's
Witnesses that Jesus is a created
Angelic
being you will not convince me that the
people behind that book Leroy FR and
others did not very carefully craft the
answers to allow for the to remain off
of them while at the same time they
didn't necessarily contradict all these
sources that were looking at they just
didn't bring them up in the book and
make Walter Martin aware of
them and once again Mrs White was
published in this issue of signs of the
times as well an article titled looking
unto
Jesus why is she not correcting this if
she wasn't on board with it when part of
her role was to protect from doctrinal
error and
deception are we honestly to believe
that she never read any of the
publication she was published in had no
clue about any of these statements which
very clearly teach that for roughly
4,000
years Jesus became an Angelic being with
an angel nature taking on the name
Michael to do Angelic Ministry to the
fallen angels to try and redeem them
before then entering into the second
step of testing and humiliation which
involved stooping down even lower and
becoming a man sheathing himself of his
Angel
nature the next month may7th 1912 issue
of signs of the
times they published the concluding
article in their studies on Daniel
series from that previous issue from the
last
month and just in case there's any
confusion or Adventists that want to try
and argue that last article didn't say
what I claimed in this one they recap
the whole series and are outright
explicit this is part of what they're
claiming can be concluded from Daniel 12
folks
quote Michael it has been shown is none
other than our Lord with Angel nature
acting as an angel servant or messenger
and because chiefest servant the chief
of all the Angels the Archangel the very
name means who is like God and he is
identified with our Lord by the
expression who standeth for the children
of thy people only Christ stands up
against all usurpers and persecutors and
deao persecuting powers of this world
close
quote Angel
nature in Angel nature not just a role
or title of authority
friends they state that he had an angel
nature along with the role of
messenger and say that Michael the the
Archangel was Jesus who had an angel
nature acted as an angel servant and
messenger who because he was the
chiefest servant was the chief of all
the Angels the
archangels but folks do you see the
glaring issue
here what have they been telling us
repeatedly is the first step of Jesus's
humiliation to become Michael the arc
Angel taking on an angel nature he did
this for roughly 4,000 years after those
4,000 years he ceased being an angel and
became a
man well Daniel 12 says Michael will
stand up which they claim his future to
us and is when he's going to return at
the second
coming but he stopped being Michael when
he became a man they told
us the name Michael was tied to him
taking on an angel nature which he
abandoned when he became a
man every step of the way this movement
is in theological hot water at every
turn they're making serious blunders
it's not small blips here and there it's
large christological heresies outright
contradictions to the plain words of
scripture the the clear dactic passages
too this is all at the behest of their
worldview claiming to have knowledge and
insight into what what was going on
before the Earth was
created they then bring those extra
details not found in the Bible to the
biblical text to try and find places to
stick them in and claim well see it's
biblical and yes Ellen White was
published in that article of signs as
well she wrote an article titled feeding
the
5000 I have all the same questions I did
previously why is she not correcting
this apparent it was an
error the next month June 18
1912 God bless those that have been here
this whole time we still got a long way
to go folks we're going up to the
1950s and it gets worse it gets worse
you're gonna want to stick around I know
some of this is repetitive but it's
driving home the point this ain't
one-offs this is not one-offs and it I'm
telling you it gets worse
it gets worse I know you're probably
thinking how just stick
around June 18 1912 once again from the
question corner where they're answering
questions from advent's Ley this time
over the subject of war in heaven
Revelation 12 7-9 someone asked the
question make sure you get
this can Revelation 12 7-9 be applied to
Satan's first fall
can Revelation 12 7-9 be applied to
Satan's first
fall aka before the creation of the
earth to which they give the
answer we think
not the first fall is set before us in
verses 3 and
four when Satan fell our Lord himself
stepped down from his highest state of
reigning with the father and took upon
himself the form of a creature in order
to save and the first step in that
downward career of sacrifice was to
become an angel Michael the
Archangel there began the spiritual
warfare between our Lord as Angel and
Satan and which continued until the time
that Christ took the Second Step
downward and died upon the cross a man
this is perfectly harmonious
with all that is taught
elsewhere close
quote I I mean it doesn't get much
clearer
folks that was the entire answer to the
question short direct to the
point first step in the downward career
of sacrifice was to become an
angel our Lord as Angel battled
Satan perfectly consistent with all
we've taught
elsewhere next time you hear an
Adventist
Source or individual try and cite
Revelation 12 and they're being war in
heaven to try and support their
pre-earth origin narrative remember this
quote their Church says no no no you
can't use those verses to support that
we think
not but they very clearly claim that
Jesus stepped down from his highest
state ruling with God the
Father something Ellen White early on
said he was exalted to or given such a
status and he took upon himself
what the form of a creature in order to
save first to try and save Angels by
taking on an Angelic nature as Michael
the
Archangel this began the spiritual
warfare between Jesus as an angel and
Satan which continued until when
when Jesus Took the second step in
Sinking even lower than an angel
becoming a man which resulted in him
ceasing being an
angel and this is perfectly harmonious
with all that they've taught
elsewhere so all those other signs
articles that we've seen so far this is
what they were teaching and putting
forth is not answering adventism
twisting the
facts very clear not not cryptic not
obscured clear as
ice this shows that they do not at all
understand basic Christian
theology Jesus atoned for the sin of
Adam Adam means man in
Hebrew as the second Adam Jesus atoned
for man's
sin there was no atonement made for
Angels no in between phase where he was
an
Angel and now we come to the source that
I've primarily been using in past
presentations the July 23rd 1912 issue
of signs of the times this article is
titled titled Our Savior and Lord and
then under the subheading Christ as
Michael the
Archangel this one is important because
of something I just got done mentioning
and because of what's going to be said
by another source later
I'll read first and then I'll
explain quote he talking about Jesus
Took the nature of angels to repeat the
first step then in his humiliation in
laying aside his divine nature was to
put on the nature of angels and thus it
is that we have Jesus brought to view as
Michael the
Archangel the commander of the hosts of
Heaven the captain of the host of the
Lord and as such the armies in heaven
follow him when he became an angel he
bore A fitting name even as when later
he became a
man his name befitted the nature which
he took by virtue of his birth into our
human
family that name was Emmanuel God With
Us his name as an angel is Michael which
signifies the one who is like
God so before
proceeding make sure you catch what is
being claimed here remember how David
asri in the opening clip as well as
questions on Doctrine they both claim
that the name Michael is just a name
given to Jesus among many names yeah
here we see the full
picture and that what they're saying
isn't the full
picture the name Michael is tied to
Jesus becoming an Angelic creature
taking on an angel ual
nature he laid aside his divine nature
like another article we saw earlier said
he set his deity
aside assumed an angel nature and was
brought to view as Michael the
Archangel and notice how they say that
when he became an angel he bore A
fitting name that befitted the nature
upon which he
assumed so as a man it was Emanuel which
means god with us but as an angel it was
Michael which means one who is is like
God but the article
continues whatever the name that he
takes in crushing sin and rebellion in
Redeeming the lost and in restoring
Harmony to the universe that name must
indicate that God is in him and with him
on the very plane and in the very nature
of the class of beings to whom he is
sent by living the god life on the plane
of angels of which Satan was one
although Fallen he could neutralize the
force of Satan's accus
ations thus when he became an angel the
fact must not be lost sight of that he
was God with the angels yet living on
their plane possessing their
natures and this thought is preserved in
the name that he bears as an angel close
quote so Jesus lived the god life on the
plane of angels meaning he kept the law
perfectly as an angel which knew
naturalized Satan's accusations in the
great
controversy he perfectly embodied the
character of
God remember what they claim that these
pre-earth accusations from Satan are
that the law is not fair it can't be
kept it needs changed Angels need no law
Etc that's what Ellen White tells us in
spirit of Prophecy volume one so part of
Jesus taking on an angel nature was to
demonstrate to the angels that these
charges Es are false and just like he
was an example to humanity of the same
thing so too he was for the
angels and as we've seen in numerous
other articles in the same publication
he was also doing this to offer
salvation to the angels and was trying
to save
them and this is what was required for
God's love to be demonstrated Satan's
accusations to be silenced and
ultimately for God to be Vindicated from
Satan's accusations which is the whole
Central thesis of their entire
system and yes Ellen White was published
in this issue of signs as
well her article was titled Christ's
Victory through pain and death no
correction from her no protection from
this Blasphemous unbiblical teaching
that contradicts the god of the word of
God
Etc you're not the Commandment keeping
church if you have an
idol that's step one
we can't even talk about the fourth
Commandment when they don't pass the
first so remember that don't get sucked
into this distraction of arguing step
four when the Adventist Church doesn't
even make it past step
one I'm not granting the first three to
them to then argue the
fourth but they don't they don't pass
the test of the fourth Commandment
either because they have a false
gospel and like Israel in Hebrews 3 and
4 who didn't believe and failed to enter
so too is the SD Church wandering around
in the
desert a stiff necked organization that
refuses to repent believe the gospel and
unless they do they're going to perish
in the wilderness of life if they don't
humble
themselves and the author of Hebrews
says that Israel missed truly entering
into the true Promised Land because they
didn't believe it wasn't just Canaan
that they missed out on they didn't
believe the gospel so they didn't go to
the true Promised Land
either see hav Church does even keep the
fourth Commandment like they think only
people who have the true gospel can
actually keep the fourth Commandment
properly nevertheless I encourage folks
to go and read the entire article in
particular in that one because what they
teach here is truly
astonishing it's all about Jesus
becoming an angel among the angels to
war with Satan and manifest his true
character of God to the fallen angels to
try and save them and a battle breaks
out and all sorts of other fic that's
nowhere found in sacred scripture sounds
like an episode of Star
Trek then in the next month August 13
1912 another one from the question
Corner this time it's titled
Michael the question is
asked could Michael have been properly
called the only begotten Son of God
except by personification before he was
born of a human mother
to which the answer is given pay very
close
attention we do not understand that the
expression this the only begotten Son of
God refers to our Lord as a human
being we do not understand that the
expression the only begotten Son of God
refers to our Lord as a human
being it seem that as if John 3:16 would
exclude
this God so loved the world that he gave
his only begotten son the giving was not
when he was born of a
woman the giving was that he might be
born of a
woman the giving was not when he became
Michael the giving was that he might
become Michael that he might step down
down down taking upon him first the
nature of angels next the nature of
humanity and so going clear down to the
lowest step which could be taken death
that when he ascended he might fill all
things what is implied in that only
begotten Son of God we do not know we
could not understand if it were told
us that is a part of the great mystery
of godliness but just how or why he is
called that we do not know in some way
in some sense the father is
preeminent this is indicated in various
scriptures and yet Jesus says I and my
father are one read also 1 Corinthians
24-28 but this only begotten Son of God
who proceeded forth and came from the
father was given and given for Sinners
given in the beginning the Lamb of God
slain before the foundation of the world
and true to that purpose when the
fullness of time came God sent forth his
son born of a woman born under the law
that he might receive the adoption of
sons and so the only begotten Son of God
was truly
Michael just the same as he was
truly
Jesus close
quote totally bizarre
folks so so the answer says
they don't understand the expression
only begotten Son of God to refer to
Jesus as a human
being
what and John 3:16 proves
this but they said in the November 24
1914 issue of signs when Ellen White was
still
alive that he who was deity first took
the form of an Angel and was Michael the
AR Angel Chief among the Angels because
Chief in service and yet he was the son
of
God and that same article was
republished again years
later so they can't keep their theology
straight this system is about as crooked
as a $3
bill we also see them claim that in some
sense the father's preeminent to the son
meaning he surpasses the son in some way
so in
1912 three years before Ellen dies well
after Desire of Ages is published and
their christology is supposed to be
cleaned up and finalized you know
they're trinitarians now you still have
it being taught that the father is
superior to Christ like back in the
early
days the titles only begotten Son of God
strictly refers to the father bringing
Jesus forth as the preeminent one over
him
yeah make of that what you will but also
that last
sentence they cap it off by saying that
the title of only begotten Son of God
can rightly be applied to Michael the
Archangel just the same as he was truly
Jesus uh no it
can't because Jesus never became an
Angel With An Angel nature and all this
other heresy that they're claiming is
biblical Hebrews 1 explicitly refutes
this without question God the father has
never called an angel his
son
ever he was never an angel as the Son of
God
period to become an Angel With An Angel
nature would mean he ceased being the
Son of God because the father never
called called an angel his
son in the same issue this is from the
Highlight section where they give
highlights of what all is contained in
the particular issue of the
magazine regarding what we just read
they write quote our Lord did not lose
his divinity or identity when he became
an angel among the Angels A man among
men while he lived his own life by faith
he possessed the power to Aid infinitely
all who needed help he was potentially
then all that he was afterward
manifested to be he's Jesus Christ the
same yesterday today and
forever close
quote so he set his divinity aside they
told us over and over but at the same
time he didn't lose it he was God on the
plane of angels with the angels and
lived the god life on the plane of
angels
except as we saw in previous issues
along with Ellen White and Desire of
Ages and the fundamental beliefs book of
the present
day as well as the SDA Church's current
website Jesus is omnipresent now through
the holy spirit because encumbered with
Humanity Jesus couldn't be
omnipresent despite Colossians 2 telling
us he's the fullness of the godhead
bodily yeah f
Divine attributes are not like light
switches they aren't just like you turn
them on and
off they're a part of God's actual
Essence his
being a part of what makes him who he
is if Christ gave up omnipresence to
Incarnate as a man then he ceased to be
God because omnipresence is part of what
makes God who he is
they can't have it both
ways like the article said he was God on
the plane of
angels so God Was An Angel With An Angel
nature at one time but after 4,000 years
discarded that angel nature and the name
Michael to sink even lower as a man
which brings forth Jesus of Nazareth who
was given the name
Emanuel where he also set his divine
nature aside but he was still somehow
God and man
however in this act he eternally
sacrificed certain Divine qualities
which resulted in him being eternally
humiliated never regaining that which he
gave up to become a
man totally bizarre folks not not just
bizarre but
heretical and I know adven are going to
try and claim this is all a mystery we
can't know the inner workings of it all
and this supposed to you know that's
supposed to to excuse all of
this no no friend the problem is the
Bible doesn't teach
this this is a different
Jesus it has nothing to do with having
perfect head knowledge around the
mechanics of this stuff it has to do
with just outright contradicting the
Bible and fitting the bill for a false
Jesus that Paul warned the churches in
Corinth
about that Jesus himself warned about in
Matthew
24:24 saying that there' be many false
christs in the last
days the SDA church needs to come out
and denounce this stuff as Blasphemous
heresy that they've repented of
teaching they need to acknowledge the
error and apologize for teaching who
knows how many people this Blasphemous
stuff because all of these sources are
in published works that were
disseminated to people to read trust and
believe
I hope you all are locked in because
we're still only about halfway through
the
pile yeah we're going on three hours and
believe it or not it gets worse I'm
telling you it gets worse the reason
we're looking at all these ones that
tend to repeats is because I want you to
see it is over and over and over again
they are bald-faced lying in this book
they knew that they were lying you're
not going to convince me otherwise stick
around because you're in for a treat
so now we go even deeper down the rabbit
hole and this is where I start to become
frustrated in the August 27 1912 issue
of signs again in the question corner
someone that was reading this
nonsense read this and had a question
from one of the previous issues about
Jesus stepping down down down after
becoming an angel and their god-given
conscience kicked in and was like what
in the heck am I reading
and notice what they ask it's a long
question they ask
quote I noticed that in your answer to
question number 37
3783 you state that our Lord himself
stepped down from his highest state of
reigning with the father and took upon
himself the form of a creature in order
to save and the first step in that
downward career of sacrifice was to
become an angel Michael the
Archangel please give me in your
question Corner your scriptural
Authority or text for making this St
statement as it is a new thought to me
that our Lord took two steps downward
before he could become man's
Redeemer we have the scripture where he
was made a little lower than the Angels
Hebrews 2:9 but can find No statement
where he was made an angel from a higher
order of being also tell me whom was he
to save in that first downward step and
how yeah great question
clearly this person's using their brain
well notice the answer
given quote in the first place our Lord
did not take two steps downward before
he could become man's Redeemer if man
had been the only order of creation
below God there would have been but the
one step but there are other beings
involved in
Sin Sin had entered in among the angels
and our God is no respector of persons
we know that his mercy endureth forever
and we know that he had the same tender
care and solicitude towards the angels
that sinned as he had toward man who
sinned but the Bible is not a revelation
to the angels but to us if it had been
God would have given us all the
particulars with all the appeal which he
must have made to them and we and he uh
and we would have we would have told us
the effort that he put forth to save
them but he's given us enough of the
revelation of his character that we may
know that he had angels in mind in the
sacrifice of the Redeemer as truly as he
did man read Ephesians 48 wherefore lie
saith when he ascended on high he led
captivity captive and gave gifts unto
men now this he as uh now this he
ascended what is it but that he also
descended into the lower parts of the
Earth he that descended is the same also
that ascended far above all the heavens
that he might fill all things close
quote yeah y'all don't have a lick of
support for this that's what we read
there a bunch of bloviating nonsense
from an individual who goes what in the
world is this article
saying furthermore the Revelation from
God that we do have in scripture tells
us in Jude that the apostate Angels
didn't have an opportunity for
Redemption the same thing in second
Peter Hebrews tells us that Jesus didn't
come to save Angels but The Offspring of
Abraham human beings he was not ashamed
to be called our brother because the Old
Testament foretold that he would
incarnate as a
man no we may not know that God had the
Ang angs in mind in the sacrifice of
Christ just as he did man Ephesians 48
has nothing to do with Jesus trying to
save angels in the Plan of Redemption
more butchering of the Bible but they
continue there is not one single vacancy
which sin has made or can make in the
universe of God but what will be filled
with the fullness of the Lord Jesus
Christ consequently there was salvation
held out to the angels through Christ
just as truly as there was to man read
the article on Christ as Michael the
Archangel in number three of this series
by g w
reer we have the facts set before us
again and again that Christ the lord was
the angel of God's presence Michael the
Archangel the angel of Jehovah the one
who served through all the past in
behalf of God's children as example to
Angels both good and evil and that this
service continued until our Lord became
human and took upon himself the nature
of the other class that of
man these suggestions with the article
referred to we are sure will help our
Inquirer to understand that the great
Plan of Salvation was full enough to
include every sinner in the universe
whether that sinner be angel or man we
do not need the statement that he was
made an angel when we read that he was
the creator of the heavens and the Earth
and then read that he was an angel
certainly somewhere the transformation
took place but when he became flesh he
continued not in the nature of
angels He took upon himself the nature
of man descended as low as death can
carry one and by right of character
ascended far above all things that he
might fill all vacancies see all the
same proof text we've heard from them
previously close quote yeah give me a
break we read that horrific article by
George reer and that's the exact one
that I told you to go read this entire
thing of signs of the times July 23rd
1912 it's hyperlink on our website in
the is Jesus the mik uh Michael the
Archangel article go read it I'm not
hiding anything I encourage you to do
the same thing go read it nothing in
that article from George reer provided
biblical proof that Jesus first became
an Angel With An Angel nature to try and
save Angels but they all rejected him so
then after 4,000 years of Waring with
the angels as an angel himself he passed
that test sheathed himself of his Angel
nature and Sh and sunk down even lower
to the level of humans where he took on
the nature of a human this being the
second step in his
humiliation we didn't get any Bible
there we got well you know just like
they do today I know it doesn't say that
but you know
but they only believe a plain thus
sayeth the Lord Ted Wilson tells
us no Jesus didn't atone for Angels he
didn't try and redeem
Angels Revelation tells us the fires of
Hell or sorry Matthew tells us the fires
of hell were prepared for the
Angels they don't provide a single shred
of actual biblical support here because
they can't this was a great
non-answer they just gave the same tired
proof text they've used in every single
one of these articles to support this
and not a single one of them holds up
you guys have squeezed that lemon
dry and no juice came
out no juice came out of that lemon not
a single one of those proof Texs
supports anything that they've been
saying
here notice they don't actually need a
statement that Jesus was made an angel
when they read that Jesus is the creator
of heavens and the Earth but then also
that he's an
angel yeah except you don't read that
he's an angel you guys do a bunch of
flip-flopping gymnastics inference on
this playing Bible
pingpong you read precisely the opposite
in the Bible that Jesus is an
angel the exact opposite that God the
father's never called called an angel
his
son but this shows you folks they
weren't just claiming that the term
angel only refers to a role or a
title no they're outright defending here
the claim that Jesus became an Angel
With An Angel nature I'm gonna keep
saying this hopefully for some of you
guys some of you Adventists it clicks at
some point you hear us and think holy
smokes I gotta get the hell out of here
oh that's old oh that's back then stick
around what verses are they referring
to of Jesus being an angel oh the
handful of Michael the Archangel texts
yet none of those say what you guys
claim but the point being this
publication is recognizing in this
answer well there's two things that are
actually seen here one is that they're
recognizing that Archangel isn't just a
title but it also refers to the nature
of angels an Angelic creature but
furthermore the person asking the
question came to the same conclusion I
did when reading these things which is
why they're asking about it and they
didn't say here no no no you're
misunderstanding that
article then we jump ahead almost
exactly one year to august 19 1913 once
again signs of the times an article
titled Bible study object lessons of
God's
mercy an article that's posing questions
and giving answers a number of questions
are asked regarding Jesus giving himself
where they give answers but then they
have a note for this section and within
that we see them mention Michael and
notice what they say
quote it was love on the part of the
Great Jehovah which moved him to give
his
son ah so the son isn't Jehovah
it was love on the part of the son which
moved him to give
himself offering his own life for a race
of Sinners and so demonstrate the love
of God to men and the Holiness the
beneficience the perfect uh the
Perfection of God's government AKA his
law the purpose of God as well as the
sacrifice of Christ was all
inclusive it embraced not only man and
this Earth but all creation
from the time of the Son of God gave
himself in that far away
beginning there began his self
abnegation his Vindication of the Divine
government his desire to save all
therefore he became an angel among
Angels Michael the Archangel Chief only
because of more devoted service
demonstrating that Angels could live for
God
God his next step brought him to the
Human family where he went to the very
lowest depths even
death that death was the climax of the
sacrifice of the ages but in all his
experience he
faltered not failed not and so became
the author of Eternal salvation unto all
them that obey him Hebrews
57-10 close
quote so we see the same old claims
being made except
notice they say the purpose of God
including the sacrifice of Jesus Christ
was all
inclusive the giving of Jesus was a
demonstration of not just God's
character of love but it also showed the
Perfection of God's government AKA his
law which is precis what their model of
redemption proposes is Central God is on
trial because Satan made accusations
after becoming jealous of Jesus being
exalted but then they write that from
the time of the Son of God giving
himself in that far away beginning he
began his
what
self-abnegation and what does the word
abnegation mean
to renounce or reject
something so for the Adventist Jesus to
vindicate God's character and his law
against
Satan it required that Jesus reject
something and they refer to him here as
distinct from
Jehovah this is another way of them
saying he set aside his divinity he
began doing this first by becoming an
angel among the
angels and he did this as their example
he did this to to show them that Satan
is a liar angels can keep the law of God
his government's good Etc just like they
teach that Jesus was the great example
for us as humans he supposedly did that
same thing for fallen
angels He then continued his
self-abnegation by sinking even lower
down to our level where he entered into
a permanent humiliation to never retain
some of the things that he
rejected in his
self-abnegation and you guessed it alen
white is published in the same issue
with an article titled the touch of
Faith why is this continually being
published alongside her for years with
no
correction other than to say she saw no
issues with these claims
then we go ahead another
year November 24
1914 same publication in the question
Corner section once again someone asked
a question about the personhood of the
Holy
Spirit within that article they
transition into talking about
Jesus where they definitively assert we
believe he was both God and man while on
Earth he did not lose identity and they
cite Philippians 2 exactly like we saw
on their website to this day but once
again they demonstrate that they can't
possibly mean this the way Christians
do or have from the very beginning of
the New Testament Church because they
once again affirm that he became an
angel and was simultaneously God as an
angel somehow quote he who existed in
the form of God yielded up all the glory
and all the honors there were in heaven
he took upon him the form of a servant
he was made in the likeness of man he
humbled himself he became obedient to
death he was raised from the dead he who
was deity first took the form of an
Angel and was Michael the Archangel
Chief among all the Angels because Chief
and service and yet he was the son of
God of whom the father said behold I
send an angel before thee to keep thee
by the way and to bring thee into the
place which I have prepared take ye heed
before him and hearken unto his voice
for my name name is in him Exodus 23 20
and 21 close quote no he wasn't Hebrews
1 says God the father never said to an
angel you are my
son this is the constant conundrum they
find themselves in and yet again we see
them conflating the angel of the Lord in
the Old Testament with Michael the
Archangel so they're wrong again and yep
you guessed it Ellen White was published
in the same issue with an article titled
educating for successful
service but it's important that we look
at one Ser uh uh One
Source out of chronology here because it
will help you better
understand the terms in this quote okay
notice it says he who was
deity he who was deity first part of
that highlighted part on screen he who
was deity
like Martin talks about in Kingdom of
the Cults the key to understanding all
of this is scaling the language barrier
with these cult groups how are terms
being
used in the August 1st 1943 issue of the
Watchman magazine get this folks in an
article titled who is Christ we read in
part
quote God is the family name of the
deity this family is composed of three
members Father Son and Holy
Ghost they are God the Father God the
son Jesus Christ and God the Holy Ghost
while we have here three distinct and
separate members of the Divine family
yet they are all one in purpose and all
bear the name
God therefore Isaiah prophesied that
when Jesus should be born his name
should be called Emmanuel and this when
interpreted is God With Us he was God
the son in the likeness of human form
close
quote how many times have I said exactly
this and I can't tell you how many
Adventists I've had tell me you don't
know what you're talking about you're
making stuff up you're a
liar this shows that when they use the
term
God they aren't using it the same way
that the Christian church
is they're using it like a familial
title like a last
name God is the family
name and this family is composed of
three distinct and separate members who
are united in a purpose
so therefore they all bear that family
name of
God so remembering questions on
Doctrine when they say we believe that
the term Michael is but one of the many
titles applied to the Son of God the
second person of the
godhead understand the phrase godhead in
light of what is laid forth
here how they also said their view of
Michael in no way conflicts with
believing in Jesus's full
deity again understand that in light of
the definition set forth here as well as
that last
quote they said he who was deity first
took the form of an
Angel and was Michael the
Archangel all that's saying is that
Jesus was a part of this God family he
shared this last name if you
will and it was that member of the
family that decided to become an
angel this is not the Trinity
folks this is three different
gods obviously they're going to hem and
ha at that but anyone that understands
the doctrine of the Trinity knows this
is not at all what was described there
this is
tritheism three distinct and separate
members of a
family and this is still how they
describe their gods to this day they use
this analogy of a team on their website
adventist.org
Trinity that each person in their
godhead concept is like three team
members who become get who come together
in a
mission and their Union in that mission
is what makes them United is
one this is not a good analogy
whatsoever when discussing
monotheism while it may work to describe
the economic actions of the
godhead they bring this analogy over to
describe God's actual being or
ontology this is like saying three band
members come together and play a song
and three band members being totally in
harmony doing their part creates the
song which is a unified end goal you
don't have the the song without all of
the members in harmony playing together
but there's still three different beings
in the
band the song doesn't result in only one
being well they are taking their team
analogy here and applying that over to
how they believe that there that there's
one God based on that quote we saw in
the Watchman
magazine a a family of three distinct
and separate members who share in a
common purpose or goal as a family and
that's supposed to make them one
God this is why analogies like this need
to be
avoided this is not the Trinity the term
God refers to the singular being that is
the almighty father son and spirit refer
to to the individual persons that that
One Singular being is expressed
through for the Adventists that might be
trying to navigate how this differs from
Orthodox Christianity what we just read
on your Church's
website you might be confused at what
Christians are saying and how it differs
by personhood or
persons the Christian church is in total
agreement that this is referring to the
conscious ability to will speak
self-reflect exhibit emotions
Etc it refers to the who who is god
father son and
spirit it's not referring to having a
literal physical tangible body or form
like Ellen White claimed to confirm by
directly talking face to face with
Jesus we see that father son and spirit
all possess the ability to speak be
spoken to Etc yet at the same time like
I will show momentarily in the in a
chart scripture is overwhelmingly clear
that there's only one almighty God and
scripture calls all three of these
persons the one almighty
God which is why we use the term being
to refer to the Oneness of God persons
refers to the plurality being refers to
the
singularity by being we're talking about
the mode or state of
existence this can has
being it doesn't have
personhood I have being and
personhood now I want to look at how
Augustine describes
This and like I did
earlier I have to
preface because we're going to get
complaints well that's not the Bible
That's B
well yeah we know we
know I'm simply showing a qualified
source for the Christian
position if Adventists want to dismiss
Augustine as being wrong then thank you
for proving my point you don't affirm
the same thing Christians
do this is from his
Masterpiece de trinitat on the Trinity
which deals a lot with Aryan heresy of
his day and age with in that he explains
why the person and being distinction is
so important pay very close attention
this book is a masterpiece a gold
mind this is from chapter 2 book four
quote the chief point then that we must
maintain is that whatever that Supreme
and divine Majesty is called with
reference to itself is is Saint
substance
wise whatever it is called with
reference to another is said not of
substance but relationship
wise I'm going to read that
again the chief point then that we must
maintain is that whatever that Supreme
and divine Majesty is called with
reference to itself is Saint substance
wise whatever it is called with
reference to another is said not of
substance but relationship wise
I actually have a typo in there folks
the word Saint should not actually be in
there it's should say with reference to
itself is substance wise sorry about
that the chief point then that we must
maintain is that whatever that Supreme
and divine Majesty is called with
reference to itself is substance wise
whatever it is called with reference to
another is said not of substance but
relationship
and that such is the force of the
expression of the same substance in
Father and Son and Holy Spirit that
whatever is said with reference to self
about each of them is to be taken as
adding up in all three to a singular and
not to a
plural thus the father is God and the
son is God and the Holy Spirit is God
and no one denies that this is said
substance wise and yet we say that this
supreme Triad is not three Gods but one
God so a quick note before continuing
he's describing here the difference
between the actual nature Essence and
being of God versus the economics or
relational aspect of
God relationally God is three the
father's not the son the son is not the
father the holy spirit's not the son Etc
they relate with one another they talk
commune Etc but at the same time God is
one being one substance the three
persons are one God they are the one the
one being but he
continues likewise the father is great
the son is great the Holy Spirit too is
great yet there are not three great ones
but one great one it's not after all
about the father alone that scripture
says you alone are the great gods Psalm
8610 as they talking about the Aryans
perversely consider but about Father Son
and Holy
Spirit again the father is good the son
is good the Holy Spirit too is good yet
there are not three good ones but one
good one of whom it is said no one is
good but the one God Mark 10:18 Luke
18:19 when the Lord Jesus was accosted
just as a man by the young man who said
good master he did not want to be taken
for just a man and so he significantly
said not no one is good but the father
alone but no one is good but the one God
Mark 10:18 Luke
18:19 the name father signifies only the
father in himself but the name God
includes him and the Son and the Holy
Spirit because the one God is a
trinity close quote
so in a moment we will look at more
scripture for
this but follow with what he explains
it's biblical
friend you know I was just talking with
an Adventist yesterday about the
athonian Creed and he's like well we
just go with the Bible friend the
athanasian Creed
is the Aryans were appealing to the
Bible the ultimate question becomes what
is the Bible saying this is why you
can't just cut yourself off from the
past
you need to consult with people that
came before you you're not smarter than
everyone
else this is from one of Augustine
sermons where he's teaching on the
Trinity and what's in the background of
his day is the Aryan
heresy well the Aryan friends were
appealing to the Bible to try and
support their views they weren't just up
and saying things and then one side was
like well we have the Bible and you
don't have the
Bible they were abusing the the language
of the
Bible which is why Augustine begins this
chapter by talking about the Greek
phrases usia and hypostasis or
hypostasis persons and substance these
are Bible
words the Bible uses these
words and he notes how the reason these
categories are vitally important is
because it is how we can understand both
the singularity and plurality of God
without falling into either the ditch of
aryanism or Unitarianism or modalism
which is a unarian heresy or the other
ditch of polytheism like
tritheism which is what inevitably
happens with all these groups that
confuse these two categories or deny
them and try and go oh it's Greek and
Pagan philosophy like the Jehovah's
Witnesses the socinians the modalist the
unitarians and yes the seventh
Adventists you'll find their materials
talking about three beings but also
three persons confusing the two Ellen
White herself did this
constantly and because they don't have a
training wheel level understanding of
trinitarian
theology it's why they make primitive
level errors like this regarding Jesus
becoming an angel the term God being a
family name Jesus setting his divine
nature aside Jesus being distinct from
Jehovah Jesus not truly being
omnipresent because cumbered with
Humanity he couldn't be and on and on
and on we sail down the heresy
River now I will save some of of some
comments about Augustine's scriptural
support because like I said I'm going to
have a chart on this shortly with a lot
more
examples but back in chronological
order in the May 3rd 1915 issue of signs
we see a perfect example of how Jesus is
a lesser Divine being in this
system many sdas are going to Hoot and
Holler and try and OB uscate but
Christians who understand basic
Christian christology yeah you're going
to see the issue just
fine in the questions and ansers section
of the paper we see a section titled
Michael the Archangel again
quote in his work Christ never took up a
railing accusation against any being
whether man or devil he could pray for
his enemies and when in conflict with
Satan took the wise course of handing
him over to Jehovah to be dealt with an
ambassador never undertakes to fight his
own battles the dispute is always
referred to the power he represents for
settlement close
quote so
notice they recognize here that Michael
didn't do the rebuking of Satan
according to Jude n yet elsewhere you've
seen how they try and say Jude n and
Zechariah 3 Prov that Michael is the
Angel of the Lord because they both said
the Lord rebuke thee and they both did
the
rebuking and this was during Christ's
work as an angel trying to save the
Angels battling with Satan for 4,000
years as we saw
earlier but also notice that they
rightly recognize that Michael is
distinguished from Jehovah by
Jude and they clearly see no problem
with this as it pertains to
Jesus Jesus as an angel was only an
ambassador for Jehovah say but he wasn't
Jehovah
himself yeah this is
heresy and it shows that when they say
Jesus retained his identity as deity
while both an angel and a man but also
set it aside they're tying thems in
knots remember what we just saw
regarding the phrase
deity Jesus can somehow be divine but
he's also distinct from Jehovah even
though scripture teaches Jesus is is
Jehovah and the term God is just a an a
family name for these three different
beings these separate distinct
beings let's break
down Jehovah because they sound like
Jehovah's Witnesses here let's break
down this phrase
Jehovah Jehovah is the name of God in
the Old Testament
okay the sacred personal name of God in
the Old Testament the Seventh Adventist
Church insists that they are
trinitarians like Christians no no
brother we believe the same thing you
do just like they insisted in questions
on Doctrine well in
trinitarianism when you ask who is
Jehovah the answer Father Son and Holy
Spirit that's the one
God there there's no dividing them in
essence substance nature being Etc
Jehovah is the one being father son and
spirit that one being is expressed in
three persons now what is the biblical
basis for this for Christians to say
this this is only a small sampling folks
I could give you hundreds I couldn't
even fit them all on the
chart this is a chart that is on our
website it shows only a handful of
examples
when we look at all of scripture and
seek to harmonize it we find that father
son and spirit are all called God
they're all said to be all- knowing all
three are said to be Creator Eternal
everywhere they see the hearts of men
resurrect Jesus and so
on yet at the same time scripture tells
us for example in Isaiah
42 that Jehovah alone created all things
Isaiah 42 says Jehovah alone created all
things okay well I can show you where
scripture also says that Jesus created
all things the spirit created all things
and the father created all
things yet also at the same time we know
that the father didn't incarnate and die
on the cross neither did the
spirit at Jesus's baptism for example
the spirit descended upon the son and
anointed him not the father not the son
descending upon himself the son is in
the water the spirit descends on the Son
and the Father pronounces the blessing
over the son who's in the water and
speaks from
Heaven Jesus said he's going to ascend
to the father not to himself he's going
to ascend to the father and him and the
father are going to send the spirit not
send
themselves trinitarianism is the only
way to be be able to explain
this scripture says there's only one
Jehovah yet that one Jehovah is said to
be father son and spirit at the same
time there is a way in which they are
not the same and that's at the economic
or relational
level this is why Christians are
trinitarians and if you're not a
trinitarian I'm sorry I know some of you
listen to this channel you're not a
Christian just as bad as
adventism because the Triune God is the
only true God some of you guys blow me
up and send me messages keep coming
you're not going to convince me on this
you have a false god friend I'm
sorry but what the SDA church has
tacitly admitted in this article is
damnable heresy it shows they're not
trinitarians despite them trying to
embrace that
title and couch their position behind
that word Jude n proves Michael isn't
Jesus
because Jude distinguishes Michael from
Jehovah the Lord yet the same Jude says
in Jude 5 that Jesus is the one Lord
Jehovah that led Israel out of Egypt and
gave them the
law that's Jehovah that did that which
means Jude didn't believe that Michael
was Jesus because he believed that Jesus
was the Lord and distinguished Michael
from the
Lord distinguishing between father son
and spirit
by calling one Jehovah and saying the
other isn't is not a valid way to
distinguish between
them they're all Jehovah a proper
distinction would be father and son not
Jehovah like like Augustine pointed
out when Jesus says God is good he
didn't say the father is good that would
have been him referring to distinctly
the father but no he refers to Jehovah
father son and spirit and Jehovah does
not change and cannot change
oh boy then skipping a few years ahead
in
1918 this time though it's the Sabbath
School
quarterly getting taught to the entire
church
globally alen white died in 1915 so
she's out of the picture
now but again now it makes its way into
the universal
teaching document for the entire SDA
Church
globally whether or not this is the
first instance I can't confirm as I've
not seen every possible Sabbath School
quarterly out there but in 1918 they
published a series of lessons on the
great
controversy in lesson n they talk about
Jesus as Michael we once again read
quote the combatants show that this
Warfare which began in Heaven above was
now containing in Heavenly or continuing
in Heavenly places that is the spiritual
realm Michael means who is like God Jude
N9 all the same proof text show this
Archangel to be identical with the Son
of God Among the Angels even as he was
Jesus the son of God among men and this
conflict was waged from the time of
sin's entrance till the word became
flesh close
quote so they repurposed one of the
articles that we read from signs of the
times and now it becomes Incorporated in
their worldwide teaching
tool all the same proof text as usual
and they reiterate that Michael is
identical with Jesus among the angels in
the conflict with Satan which began in
heaven and this conflict waged on from
the time of sin's entrance into the
universe until Jesus sunk lower and
became a
man worldwide Church teaching
recognizing all of what was published in
the signs
articles so they can't dismiss this as
an individual opinion by individual
people in those articles it's being
taught in the Sabbath School quarterly
that Jesus was an angel and that his
name was Michael not just that he had
the role of an Angel as a messenger but
was an angel among the
Angels just like mountains of other
quotes that we've looked
at then in 1919 they republished The
Identical articles from the August 13
1912 issues of signs as well as the
November 24th 1914 issue that we looked
at
and in 1923 they republished another
article about Daniel seeing a ram a goat
and a little horn and simply mentioned
Jesus being Michael in
passing then on August 14 1928 they
published an article in this issue of
signs of the times titled chaining
Satan which is addressing what they
claim will happen to Satan during the
millennial Reign that they believe is
future to us quote
in Jude 6 the fallen angels are
represented as being reserved in
Everlasting chains under Darkness under
the Judgment of the great day they are
bound over to the judgment and cannot
Escape it the first link in the chain of
events that ends Satan's deceiving
career for a thousand years is the
coming of the mighty angel from
heaven in fact the events that bind
Satan happen in connection with this
Angel's Advent
who is this Angel who has the power to
lay hold of the great Rebel and bind and
imprison him it's none other than
Michael the Archangel who defeated
Lucifer in the first battle around the
Throne of God Revelation 12
7-9 and who contended with him over the
body of Moses because Satan disputed his
right to raise the dead Jude nine close
quote so notice now we're starting to
see some new aspects being addressed
that we didn't see in the other
articles they state that the first link
in a chain of events that will result in
ending Satan's career as a deceiver was
the coming of a mighty angel from
heaven and The Binding of Satan happened
in connection with this arrival of this
Angel and who do they say the angel is
none other than Jesus as Michael who
defeated the devil in their first battle
around the throne citing Revelation 12
7-9
but hold up back in the June 18 1912
issue of signs someone asked the
question can Revelation 12 7-9 be
applied to Satan's first fall and what
was their
response we think not the first fall is
set before us in verses three and
four yet here they are applying
Revelation 12 7-9 to the first fall of
Satan
the first fall of Satan supposedly
happened when the first battle happened
which is what they mention
here totally contradicted what they
previously advised schizophrenic
theology but amazingly they don't site
the verse but it appears as though
they're saying Revelation 20 verse1 is
referring to Jesus as Michael the
Archangel that verse saying then I saw
an angel uh coming down from heaven
holding in his hand the key to the bot
was pit and a great
chain what is this simply more proof
that in 1928 folks they're still
teaching that Jesus was an angel having
an Angelic nature that he tried to save
angels as an angel and received the name
Michael when he became an angel and in
this instance apparently Jesus is the
angel that comes down with a chain to
bind
Satan I mean which would make sense
considering the literal title of the
article is chaining
Satan but then they continue in the same
article the struggle for the supremacy
of this world and man continued when
Michael came to this earth clothed in
human
flesh and Satan the Fallen Angel
attacked him with all his cunning and
fury again the Archangel was Victorious
and he triumphed death on the cross
sounded the Doom of Satan's revolt the
next great act in the drama is the
return of Michael the Archangel to chain
imprison and finally destroy the arch
Rebel and forever end his notorious
career he alone has the right and the
power to do this for he became flesh and
blood that through death he might
destroy him that had the power of death
that is the devil Hebrews
2:14 Christ is to finish the task he
began in heaven that of putting down the
revolt and reconciling the universe to
God God close
quote so again they contradict the
previous signs of the times articles
which told us repeatedly that Jesus
ceased being Michael upon incarnating in
human
flesh yet here they're now saying he was
still Michael when he be when he came to
Earth clothed in human flesh and his
battle with Satan as a man was simply an
extension of his 4,000-year battle with
him as an angel
except the July 23rd 1912 issue of signs
of the times the one I said to go and
read the whole one George reeeer said
that the name Michael was tied to the
nature that he assumed in becoming an
angel and that as an angel his name was
Michael but as a man it was Emanuel the
name being tied to the
nature So based on that article and this
one it would mean that Jesus was
allegedly God an angel and a man at the
same time because because he was Michael
In the Flesh they say but they've
repeatedly insisted he didn't lose his
identity as a as
deity talk about a mess of
Confusion And the fact that they'll
proof text
Hebrews and Jude like we saw yeah Jude
refutes this idea that he tried to seek
and to save
Angels the fact that they will proof
text Hebrews to the detriment of the
surrounding passages which utterly
obliterate this entire narrative that
they want us to believe is biblical I I
mean
my truly
astonishing it goes to show how how not
much has changed folks in the present
day fast forward to the September 17
1929 issue folks buck up it gets even
worse and an article titled when God
spoke from Sinai they once again talk
about Michael quote well they're never
talking about Michael though in their
Publications hardly ever
right no no we have it kind of worked
out in our theology but in our printed
Publications and our teaching yeah we're
not really talking about it that much
quote but the perplexity may arise as to
how any Angel could be called the Lord
and God uh yeah
in the book of Jude we read an account
of a contention between the devil and
one called Michael the Archangel as to
which of them should claim the body of
Moses there is one Angel then who is
called the Archangel which means head
over all the Angels who's known to the
angels of heaven as their Commander or
Michael but to God's people on Earth
he's known as the Lord Michael is the
Lord for he alone has the power to
forgive sins and to raise the dead close
quote
qu except Jude distinguishes Michael
from the Lord the previous publication
and Ellen White already recognized this
now they're saying no Michael is the
Lord I mean does it get any more
obvious folks how many times will they
blunder
this if you're an Adventist and you're
hearing in this Jude distinguishes
Michael from the Lord
different Jude nine says Michael didn't
rebuke Satan but left it to the Lord to
do the
rebuking Jesus is the Lord Lord means
Almighty Jehovah that's not a proper way
to distinguish between Father and
Son to say well Jesus left the rebuking
to Jehovah no Jesus is Jehovah
I don't think they get this I've heard
some of them make their they still make
these same claims to this day it's like
folks you don't understand what you're
talking about they already recognized
multiple times as did Ellen White that
Michael isn't the Lord Lord is Jehovah
there Michael left the rebuking of Satan
to
Jehovah every single turn they
contradict themselves and the biblical
text because we already saw two where
Ellen White who holds more Authority
than this author claim that there's
multiple
archangels and she was allegedly
divinely
inspired and she was dead by this point
so it's set in
stone but they contradict themselves
again because at the end of the article
they give a summary where they write in
part
quote summing up all the evidence of the
question on who spoke and wrote the Ten
Commandments upon Mount Si were led to
the infallible conclusion
that Christ the son of God existed
before the world began that he was the
creator of all the worlds that before he
came to this earth to die as a man he
was the honored and beloved commander of
all the angels of heaven and that his
name as a captain of the Heavenly Host
was Michael the Archangel which mean
which means the head over the Angels
only in this sense however is Christ
referred to as an angel close quote
wow
wow come on
man so they're led to the infallible
conclusion that Jesus is Michael who
before coming to this Earth was beloved
by the angels and known to them as
Michael who was head over the angels and
only in this sense can he be referred to
as an
angel except they've repeatedly been
telling us in this same publication for
the last 40 years that the name Michael
was tied to Jesus taking on an angel
nature to do Angelic Ministry to try and
seek and save the angels in the first
step of his humiliation then after 4,000
years of Waring with Satan as an angel
he sunk even lower sheathing himself of
his Angel nature to assume the nature of
a man yet now they're saying he's only
an angel in the sense that he was a
messenger and this is an infallible
conclusion
a total mess of
confusion this is supposed to be the
organization that's been given the
theological God Particle the great
controversy theme which is allegedly the
antidote to theological Division and
confusion it's supposed to unite
Adventists and their theology more than
anyone else out there and help identify
them as God's Remnant people at the end
of time who are united unlike anyone
else yeah a pipe dream a a
fantasy folks I know this is a lot but
hang in there because it's going to get
worse I'm telling
you yes the closer we approach to the
publishing date of questions on Doctrine
it gets
worse now we come to Lifeboat
magazine the January 1st 1932 issue
where they published an article titled
the chief
Shepherd in there they talk about
Michael again under the subheading of
Christ the chief Shepherd of
angels
yeah pay very close attention there's a
lot that they say here tighten your
jaws
quote among angels He was known as
Michael the Archangel the chief prince
the prince of princes Michael was CH was
Christ's prehuman
name he was of so many angels cherubim
and seraphim that inspiration speaks to
them as an innumerable
company as an example do you remember
the occasion long before Christmas when
Joshua saw a man over against the wall
of
Jericho do you remember how Joshua
rushed forward with a drawn sword and
asked are you for us or against us do
you remember the pl the reply from the
Archangel
Michael as captain of the Lord's host I
am now come take off thy shoes from thy
from off thy feet for the ground whereon
thou standest is Holy he indeed was the
only one who could command the hundreds
of millions that made up the armies of
heaven so
pause so Michael was his prehuman
name yet they claim
that Michael standing up in Daniel 121
is referring to Jesus standing up just
before the second coming but we've
already seen a mountain of sources that
say he set his divinity aside and
assumed the name Michael when he took on
an angel nature to do Angelic Ministry
to the angels and then sheathed himself
of his Angelic nature to become a man
but they
continue the time has come when he the
chief must leave heaven and his mighty
Celestial host to bid them ad do
though a shepherd of angels for
eons and Junior partner and part owner
with his father in his vast and opulent
Estates he must lay aside his commission
as Grand Marshal of Heaven which he held
through all the celestial ages break
with his associates and
go he was willing to give up
all prophecy had marked the hour of his
departure from Heaven all the time of
his going and emptying of himself Drew
near Angels hovered about him they held
him fast in their bonds of love and wept
they would not let him
go so Jesus was a junior partner and
part owner with God the father of the
Heavenly estate what bro what are you
talking about man but he laid that aside
to become an angel and be the head of
the angels as
Michael notice there's no mention of the
Holy Spirit
here but yeah they're totally
trinitarians so he's an angel with the
angels for all these years and they're
clinging to them and they're sad
and his part
owner a part associate it just
yeah
yeah totally
trinitarians part owner Junior partner
to God the father got
it and when the time came for Jesus to
cease being an
angel they wept apparently and hovered
around him holding fast to him because
they didn't want to let him cease being
an angel and becoming a man and sinking
down to our level
no attempt to provide a proof text of
course but they
continue through the Eternal ages the
purpose of the Son of God had been to
give up his glory life his God nature
all as a ransom for one lost
sheep do you think that God could give
up his only son his darling son without
a struggle never never was there a
parting like this for never never was
there a Shepherd like him in the midst
of their sorrow he was overheard to say
again in the tenderest tones of
love I must
go let us go in your stead cried out an
unders
sheeper wheither I go ye cannot answered
the chief
Shepherd the prince of his footsteps LED
down down down from the precipitous
Heights of the glory of where his
struggling wounded lost Shea the scene
changes close
quote there you have it folks this is in
1932 through the Eternal
ages it was always the purpose of the
Son of God to
what give up his glory
life his God
nature to become a man
but in the other sources they insist he
was God Among the angels and God among
men he was God on their plane even
though he set his divine nature aside
they told us numerous times
before and now they're saying he gave up
his divine
nature not just that he set it aside but
that it was always the purpose of the
Son of God to do
this and this is why you'll have sdas in
the modern day that do indeed believe
that Jesus forever gave up his divinity
to save humans this Divinity that was
the Divinity that was bestowed upon him
by the father in this pre-earth
exaltation and they see this as this
Grand Act of love and this sort of
whimsical the
drama
disgusting this is this like Jesus is my
boyfriend type just so disgusting
this is why sources like this
information like this floating around
through the decades in this movement
where they're outright saying this this
is why you have sdas in the present day
movement that think this way because yes
this is what they were
teaching if you can remain in this
movement after seeing all this may God
have mercy on your
soul yeah the true God
give I hope he gives you eyes to see and
ears to hear this is Blasphemous heresy
it isn't loving it isn't true it
contradicts the Scriptures it demotes
Jesus Christ it's insulting to the Lord
Jesus Christ and this organization ought
to be ashamed of itself for even
publishing this
heresy they need to come out and
denounce all of this as heretical but it
won't happen because it's at the
core it's at the core of the great
controversy
worldview it's just buried in all these
sources that they probably hoped that no
one would find and bring up in the
modern day well here we
are and I'm not GNA let this
die
okay if you're one of these guys up at
Tacoma Park I know you guys watch
because you contact me I'm not letting
this die
and neither is anyone else in this
audience
now now you're all seeing why this took
so long to get to get to get put
together can hardly even
talk wrapping my head around all this
has taken
months and let's not even get into this
silly dramatization of dialogue between
the AVST Jesus and the father struggling
to let the son sacrifice his divinity
forever ever and to Incarnate as a man
to save humans and the angels and just
like a bad Broadway skit it's like
obviously the Bible says nothing about
this silliness they're getting this from
Ellen White they're getting this from
Ellen White it's clearly built upon this
quote from Ellen White who said her
angel told her that the father struggled
in yielding up his dearly beloved Son in
is becoming a man to apparently give up
his God nature according to that article
despite the fact that again they told us
numerous times and signs of at the times
that Jesus was God with the angels and
God with man hence why he's known to
humans as Emanuel God With Us such a
mess then in the June 1st 1932 issue of
the Oriental Watchmen they published an
article titled the war of a million
worlds where they write quote read the
history of that war in heaven that
mightiest of all conflicts as narrated
by a scribe of Jehovah greater than
Cage's History of the United States in
50 words it reads or or in in 50 words
it reads only 68 are used to give us an
account of that first great battle
talking about Revelation and there was
war in heaven Michael and his angels
fought against the dragon and the dragon
fought with his angels and prevailed not
neither was their place found anymore in
heaven and the Great Dragon was cast out
that old serpent called the devil and
Satan which deceiveth the whole world
world he was cast out into the Earth and
his angels were cast out with him
Revelation 12 7-9 close quote but pause
[Music]
again this contradicts signs of the
times once
again the question Corner said
Revelation 12 7-9 doesn't refer to this
first fall in battle with Satan in
heaven yet we have another publication
that's using that text to support such
they continue later in the article by
saying 6,000 years have passed since
that tragedy in the garden Eastward
6,000 years of sickness misery sin and
death Untold Millions have lived their
miserable life uh lifespan of of life
and passed into the grave a countless
sea of humanity has tossed and billowed
th Through the Ages discouraged numbed
deadened no certainty of life beyond the
grave no salvation within them eles yet
a higher than Lucifer has won for us the
victory the Conqueror Michael came to
this planet alone and left behind him
his host he took upon himself the Garb
of humanity and after 30 years of daily
conflict against the deadly web of sin
which inshes each of us he won a second
Victory Upon A rugged wooden cross
erected by Augustus Caesar's created
legionaries close quote
so again apparently he was still Michael
when he was on Earth yet they told us
they had an
infall Michael took upon himself human
nature the Garb of humanity yet signs of
the times July 23rd 1912 told us that
the name Michael was tied to the nature
that he assumed in becoming an angel and
then Emmanuel was tied to the name of
him taking on a human nature what this
shows is that this movement has never
been precise they don't see all of this
as a problem who cares if you're loose
and flippant with your christology and
the claims that you make about God
himself they're the Commandment keeping
church but they have no issue being
loose around making sure you're not
putting forth an idol violating the
first
commandment now I'm going to skip over
signs of the times June 16 1942 because
they just repeat stuff we've already saw
that Michael's the only
Archangel and in
18443 is where we saw them claim God is
a familial
title so just note that they talked
about this stuff again before this next
article then in the July 24 1945 issue
of signs of the times they published an
article titled our friends the Angels
get
this an article dedicated to describing
what angels are and particularly focuses
on refuting the claim that angels are
The Departed spirits of humans obviously
a wacky concept but notice
quote it is precisely because angels are
definite uh Heavenly personalities that
they are distinct from man and cannot
possibly be the spirits of our dead
loved ones notice how clearly Paul makes
this difference in 1 Corinthians 6:3
know ye not that we shall judge Angels
how much more things that pertain to
this life angels are Heavenly while men
are of this life note the clear
differences stated in Hebrews
2:16 verily he took not on him the
nature of angels but he took on him the
Seed of Abraham it was because of this
separation in nature that the
Incarnation had to be in humanity as
shown in the context since then the
children are shares in Flesh and Blood
he also himself in like manner partook
of the same verse 14 close
quote so now they entirely contradict
every they've been saying repeatedly up
to this point and they confirm what I
said in Hebrews 1 and
2 yet in all these previous Publications
they told us they had an infallible
understanding in one in one of
them where they're trying to support
against all of what we just
read claiming that Jesus first took on
the nature of an Angel to try and save
Angels but they all rejected him so then
sunk lower in the second phase of
humiliation where he took on a human
nature schizophrenic theology folks they
don't even know what they
believe it's an Ever moving
goalpost and the same article reiterates
it again
quote they're not developed from one
original stock talking about angels as
man is no such common nature binds the
angels together as in the case with the
race of men in his Incarnation Christ
could do that with Humanity by taking
the common nature of all men but to the
angels he could not give help in this
respect see Hebrews 2:16 close quote
what bro what are you talking about
man the exact thing that I said which
refutes and contradicts everything
they've been teaching their members
through this paper the Sabbath School
quarterly The Watchman magazine the
Oriental Watchmen and so on
they were just telling us all those
years that Jesus Took upon himself in
Angel nature to seek and save the Angels
now they're promoting this actually
can't be possible because Hebrews
refutes it because Angels don't share in
a common nature so Jesus couldn't take
on one of their Natures like he could
with
humans and what did they tell us in the
June 6th 1911 issue of
signs that we can know that Jesus became
an angel to try and save the Angels
because that's how God pleads now and he
never changes and since he's eternally
the same that proves Jesus became an
angel to plead with them and repent and
be saved but 34 years
later well never mind Hebrews actually
refutes that Jesus could become an angel
because Angels don't share in a unified
nature like
humans flee from this folks flee from
this organization they don't know what
they're talking about
okay there's so many other things I
could point out that contradicts this
that they were saying earlier it's just
all over the
place now we're getting closer to Walter
Martin's publishing of the kingdom of
the
Cults we're now up to the
1950s when he was doing his re research
and meeting with the leaders of the SDA
Church doing the research for his book
which was published in
1965 okay 15 years from this point in
the January 177 1915 issue or 1950 issue
of signs of the times they published an
article titled war in heaven here we go
again remember five years before this
they're saying Jesus couldn't help the
Angels because they don't have a common
nature but humans do so Jesus was able
to take on a human nature and help
humans according to Hebrews but not
Angels
quote the symbol of the great red dragon
that of the woman was seen by the
Apostle John in heaven this is true
first of all because the war between the
two began in heaven we found that
primarily the dragon is the devil and
Satan who as Lucifer was once in heaven
an honored official in the kingdom of
God the first phase of the long struggle
between Michael and the once Mighty
Lucifer took place in heaven around the
Throne of the
Eternal the record is and there was war
in heaven Michael and his angels fought
against the dragon and the dragon fought
his angels and prevailed not neither was
their place found anymore in heaven and
the Great Dragon was cast out that old
serpent called the devil and Satan which
deceiveth the whole world he was cast
out into the Earth and his angels were
cast out with him Revelation 12
7-9 so pause before moving forward I'm
going to say it again remember what the
question Corner regarding waren Heaven
told us some de
prior they said Revelation 12 7-9
doesn't support this first fall of Satan
this first battle around the throne and
this supposed War taking place prior to
Earth's existence yet here they are once
again using it to support exactly that
using the phrase of first
phase and what did this pre-earth war
between Jesus and Satan take place
over the Throne of the Eternal
and as they've repeatedly told us up to
this point the first phase what did that
involve Jesus becoming an angel
receiving the name Michael and battling
with Satan for 4,000 years until he
stopped being an angel and became a
man folks the Bible nowhere says or
teaches that prior to the Earth's
existence Satan and Jesus were engaged
in a battle over the Throne of the
Eternal seemingly implying that Jesus
isn't the
Eternal they constantly depict Jesus and
Satan as rival equals in this article
watch them do exactly that because they
continue because the war between the two
great antagonist began in
heaven the symbols first appeared to the
prophet as being in
heaven after the struggle was
transferred to this earth it has
continued to be a Warfare between the
forces of righteousness on the one hand
and on the other hand principalities and
powers and the rulers of Darkness of
this world and wicked Spirits in
Heavenly places see Ephesians
6:12 even though this Earth is the
battlefield the struggle is being waged
over The Possession and rulership of the
world which though Fallen is still a
part of God's Kingdom for the 4,000
years before Calvary Satan carried on
his Warfare against Christ and his
church on Earth on Earth chiefly from
his position Before the Throne of God as
the prince of this world close
quote so Jesus and Satan are two great
antagonists think about
that as if there's even a
comparison talk about exalting Satan by
demoting the almighty Son of
God and they continue to portray things
like this the article continues under
the subheading of of the origin of sin
were they
right the leading
actors in this great Heavenly Warfare
for which Wicked Spirits in high places
are responsible are Prince Michael and
Prince
Lucifer hello anybody
home the leading actors in this great
Heavenly War Warfare for which Wicked
Spirits in high places are responsible
are Two Princes Prince Michael and
Prince
Lucifer Michael means like unto God and
Christ Alone is in the image of the
invisible God he's declared to be the
express image of his person or the
effulgence of his glory in the very
image of his substance see Hebrews 1:3
in Daniel 10:13 through and 21 and
Daniel 121 Michael is said to be the
first prince in the kingdom of God
and the great Prince which standeth for
the children of thy people he will
eventually stand up to reign as the
supreme ruler of this
world the angels of Michael are those
who remained loyal to him during the
Great crisis Chief among these was
Gabriel Hero Of God catch this because
of his heroism during the Revolt of
Lucifer and his angels which may have
been largely responsible for the right
decisions of the other 2/3 Gabriel was
exalted to take the position of the
first of the anointed covering cherubs
made vacant by the fall of
Lucifer to Mary Gabriel said I am
Gabriel that stand in the presence of
God to Daniel he said there is none that
holdeth with me in these things but
Michael your prince close quote hold the
phone notice we have another
contradiction what did they tell tell us
years prior in 1910 when Ellen White was
still
alive that Gabriel took Jesus's position
after he was exalted but now they're
telling us Gabriel took Lucifer's
position when he
fell wait too this
woman I mean
they claimed that during the Heavenly
revolt and war between Michael and
Lucifer due to his
heroism Gabriel was exalted to the
position left vacant by
Lucifer the Bible nowhere says any of
this
folks it doesn't say anything about
Gabriel changing any positions Angelic
promotions a war before earth existed
Etc and Jesus isn't a prince he's
Jehovah the almighty
God just citing proof texts that don't
say what they're claiming doesn't
therefore make the belief
biblical anyone can do that for all
sorts of
things I could make all sorts of
assertions and then just cite a proof
text and now be like well it's
biblical no it's not how it works
doesn't mean I'm handling the Bible
properly then in the m 28 1953 issue of
the Bible in our times which was also an
official publication seeking to teach
what the Bible says about the end times
we find an article titled which was the
first world war get this where once
again we see them talking about this
fairy tale but within that we read quote
we usually think of the expression the
first world war as applying to the war
that lasted from 1914 to 1918 but in
actual fact the first world War Began
some 6,000 years
ago what is even more amazing this war
is still raging and even now approaching
its Climax and conclusion another
astonishing fact about this first world
war is that it did not begin on this
Earth but in
heaven the apocalypse as its name
signifies lifts the curtain that
conceals the Heavenly Universe from our
view and reveals the nature and
contestants in this Mighty conflict and
then they cite Revelation 12 7-9
again close
quote so yet again they contradict what
they've previously claimed that
Revelation 12 7-9 can't be used to
support this first phase pre-earth
battle that started in heaven supposedly
yet they do so
again and no this isn't an astonishing
fact it's tot fiction and speculation
fairy tale
imaginings Revelation 12 has nothing to
do with before the Earth's existence but
then notice something
else quote note the vital truths that
are brought to our attention in this
intriguing scripture two Mighty beings
are engaged in deadly combat one is
called
Michael other scriptures help us to
identify Michael whose name means who is
as God the angel Gabriel calls him
Michael the first Prince Michael your
prince and Michael the great Prince
Daniel 10:13 close
quote uh yeah except that Daniel 10 says
Michael's the only one or or is only one
of the archangels like we saw
earlier but notice Michael is referred
to as a separate being from God Jesus
and Satan are two Mighty beings and
Jesus as Michael is a separate being
from God
this is an example of what I pointed out
earlier they don't understand these
words in this
language and lastly we come to the final
Source losing my
voice this time from ml
Andreas you go a lot lot of stuff on
this
gentleman I'm not going to give a
historical background on him but that's
who wrote this article signs of the
times December 28 1954 this article says
a lot of the same stuff the others have
so I'm just going to focus on the
specifics the something that's a little
bit different he says quote when Lucifer
planned to claim godhood there was only
one that stood between him and
God and that was Michael there would
therefore be every reason why Satan
should oppose Christ if he got him out
of the way the road would be
clear close
quote so when Lucifer planned to claim
godhood the only thing standing between
him and God
God was
Jesus yet again demoting the almighty
word Blasphemous
heresy very plainly showing that over
and over and over
again they evidence they do not
understand the
Trinity they supposedly had all that
ironed out by the 1890s when Desire of
Ages was published according to Jerry
Moon yet here they are in the 19
50s talking about Jesus being a stop gap
between Lucifer and God speaking of
Jesus as though he isn't God but the
father
is and then we get radio silence
regarding this mess about Michael three
years before questions on Doctrine is
published and we see what I read at the
beginning where they try and act like
their belief in this area is basically
just the same idea the Protestant
reformers so a number of things in
conclusion
folks the first is that questions on
Doctrine was deceptive and what they
claimed is not true aside from that
their view isn't identical to the
Jehovah's Witnesses but that doesn't get
them off the
hook the teaching is comprehensively
just as bad as the Jehovah's
Witnesses this was being regularly
published about people in the movement
were asking questions about it having
read these articles it was taught in the
Sabbath School quarterly to the entire
church and continued getting published
until right before they knew the kingdom
of the Cults was being produced had
Walter Martin known about these sources
he would have absolutely included
seventh day adventism in the main part
of the book he wouldn't have put him in
the appendix as heterodox there is zero
chance of that had he been aware of
these sources as a Baptist Minister he
would have been absolutely flabbergasted
and I wish he was still alive
today especially considering what we saw
with him on John Ankerberg where he
later found out after the book was
published where he came across sources
where they're talking about Ellen White
being the infallible interpretive
Authority you could tell in that
discussion he clearly felt like he was
misled by the SDA leaders and that he
got
Hoodwinked after questions on Doctrine
was published ministers ended up getting
fired for standing by what was stated in
the book this is what caused Martin's
confusion which then led to
him re-evaluating essentially his
assessment of the doctrines which we got
an insight into on Ankerberg so if he
would have known about these statements
regarding Jesus becoming an Angel With
An Angel nature to try and save Angels
he would have absolutely labeled them as
cultic secondly until the SDA Church
officially comes out and denounces these
claims as heretical there's no reason to
believe this has
changed it's part of the larger great
controversy framework which is Central
to AVST theology as a whole it isn't
just a side issue or a secondary matter
it's allegedly part of Jesus's work his
person and work that's what the gospel
is it's part of his person part of his
person he became an angel part of his
work save the
Angels it's allegedly part of his work
and his humiliation and the aous god
vindicating himself and his character
which they tell us is the central Crux
of their theological system pointing to
random individual Adventists to say well
they disagree or what have you is not a
sufficient reputation of the Mountain of
primary sources that we just looked at
these s these sources hold more
Authority than just any individual
random Adventist they're published by
the organization itself with their stamp
of approval I understand many Adventists
will say they disagree with what we saw
that's great praise God but that wasn't
the point of this my point wasn't that
every Adventist in the world believes
this it was that the system of theology
absolutely does and you can't divorce it
from
that at the end of the day they were
repeatedly teaching this idea of Jesus
taking on the nature of angels and that
this was necessary for God to vindicate
his character which is the entire
heartbeat of adventism so I'm not sure
how the leadership could claim that
things have now
changed thirdly Ellen White was alive
when the majority of this was being
published especially the most damaging
quotes which were right at the tail end
of her life not when she was a young
ignorant
teenager you know they love to do the
well she got Progressive understanding
over time and no toward the end of her
life some of the worst
quotes where are her rebukes and
correction as the protector of doctrinal
error that is unless she didn't believe
it to be error which is why we can't
find
them the organization tells us that part
of her function and role is to protect
avenus from doct confusion and deception
yet she was published alongside a lot of
these statements in the same exact
Publications that state this
stuff and if she corrected it at some
point why did it continue to
happen four this is a false god a false
Christ and Christians and Adventists
alike need warned about this no they
don't teach the same thing as the
Jehovah's Witnesses don't make that
mistake but understand it is just as
problematic
while some of the SDA Pioneers were
Aryans like the Jehovah's Witnesses the
organization officially pivoted off of
that but as you saw in some of the
quotes they're still demoting the
sun distinguishing him from Jehovah he's
a stop gap between Lucifer becoming
God the Jehovah's Witnesses teach Jesus
is a created angel named Michael the SDA
church is teaching here that Jesus
became an angel at a certain point he
wasn't created taking upon himself an
Angel nature to try and save the angels
and vindicate the law before the Angels
against Satan's accusations about it but
then he sheath himself of that angel
nature when he incarnated as a man
moving to a second phase of his work of
humiliation which was incarnating as a
man something that he will retain
forever in an eternally humiliated State
never to regain back some of his Divine
likee qualities such as
omnipresence those are both both
heretical and cultic doctrines placing
both the Jehovah's Witnesses and the
Seventh Day Adventist outside of the
Christian faith
okay now I know that was a lot but if
you were a Seventh Day Adventist and you
heard all that and you can remain in
this organization may God have mercy on
your
soul you can try and make all the
excuses oh my pastor doesn't talk about
that or oh I've never heard this before
you're coping friend you're coping if
you think this is the Commandment
keeping
Church who's talking about a Jesus that
was an angel and all this nonsense we
just looked at may God have mercy on
your soul thank you all so much for
being here hopefully you found this
information uh helpful informational
hopefully it got you caught up to speed
pocket these def or uh sources so that
you can reference back to these things
you can reference back to this there
will be timestamps in the the
description eventually so there'll be
time stamps throughout the whole video
so you can easily go back and reference
things may Christ richly bless you in
the grace and peace won by him and his
vicarious death on the cross for Sinners
Not Angels until next time God bless
[Music]